[Music]
foreign
emily uh i have in my notes here that
you got a dm
about a guy who wants you to give
yourself a wedgie
i did i had a gentleman caller
uh enter a slide i believe it's called
slide into your dms i can't stop looking
at myself you look good
let's use the monitor for emily this is
emily's first time
with the monitor on where'd i go um
i it's like charlotte's chocolate
factory when the kids saw himself on the
tv he got small
now you're just looking in the
blackberry movie she's like where did
you go
like i have to look at myself constantly
um
i had a gentleman dm me and say
i will pay you seventeen
no i think it was it was seven thousand
eight hundred dollars which is very
weird seventy eight hundred dollars
uh to watch someone give you a wedgie
seventy five hundred dollars
seventy eight hundred dollars seventy
eight hundred seven
thousand eight hundred dollars so let's
just slow down he picked this number
he did no i wasn't negotiating with it's
a weird way place to start
yeah uh started seventy eight hundred
dollars
so now i i would what would i'm sorry if
i would if that was my thing and i was
going to dm someone out of the blue
that's not that's not that wasn't where
i would start
why i wouldn't here's the thing about
this guy that asks where would you start
the biggest problem with this man he's a
bad businessman you never come in that
high on your first offer i know that was
the problem i'm looking i would have
i would have given myself a wedgie for
i would have been like ten thousand
dollars really
yes he's gonna have that video forever i
have tattoos
what is the value of video
well rude how do you put a price on
emily getting a wedgie
but the weird it's priceless the weird
thing i'm trying to find i had a friend
in nashville who a guy would message her
and she would fart in videos for him
that's just that's just good business
walk me through that
uh she got a message from this guy one
time and he was like hey will you
fart for me on on video and i'll give
you i think like 700 dollars like that
it was somewhere like seven five
something like that and she was like as
a joke we were all sitting there and she
was like i'm gonna be like yeah tell me
what you did
and then and then she was like do i have
to be on camera like my whole face and
he was like no
and so she did it so he she's like vin
mommy first she mowed it and she did it
and i'm an idiot and then now he she
does it like every month or so
how do you find her instagram so
the guy that dm'd me said 7800 i did my
face didn't have to be in it
and he'd venmo me first but then i asked
i prefer
the people do you mean like i prefer
your face isn't in it yeah i said i
don't know
yeah i said i'll give you the wedgie for
half that's ridiculous i mean i could
give
i could find someone do it much cheaper
than that but then my mom well now i
know where i stand in your life you
asked your mom
if you could do it emily she said
absolutely not i can't believe you're
even considering it i'm so disappointed
in you
that's what she said verbatim your mom
no well not verbatim but she was like oh
this is you're kidding right and i was
like well i was running it by i was
floating it past you
if you can send someone a video of you
getting a wedgie
for 7 800 and you don't do it
you're bad at business right or you have
really good morals
but what morals are also subjective
subjective
i just it made me feel gross well yeah
no
shit so you would i shouldn't do
something for money that makes me feel
gross
78 hundos 7 800
i know wedgie i know did you respond
people send pictures so i put it as a
joke i screenshotted it and put it in a
story and said of course
and then she responded back are you
serious oh
my no no no then i got the parameters
okay there we go
and then what happened well that's when
he offered up front venmo
and no face in the video no face in the
wedgie video what do you mean offer no
face
oh he said your face doesn't have to be
in it like we were negotiating
and then emily said what if i want it to
be
and he's like what if i want to put two
little two little stickers on my face
right on my booty
wait oh no oh no is there like a
protocol like how do we send it
do you want a dropbox link you didn't
get that far i don't and i don't know
there's something so funny to me about
trying to send like um
news to someone or a video to get hustle
and like i can't figure a fucking
dropbox
like i would totally be an online sex
worker right now
if i could figure out dropbox i have
announcements to make
an announcement i said i love you to a
man
on purpose are you related to him
were you at your dad's grave was it
benton
was it a dog you have to be on camera
this is being filmed
i said i love you to a man was he in the
room
does he know you can you give us all the
specifics we need more details
uh i'm very weird about saying i love
you you have to take a break
take
but also all your teeth are green and
black it looks wild
wait what it's like it's like a look and
where i'm like i don't know i don't want
people to see it
wait i started just eating these as
snacks i thought
those are vitamins whitney these are
daily essential vitamins you take
one other little snacks
no this is a sponsor you're gonna get a
uti
oh no don't spit out as sponsors
we live no it's
yo swamp witch over here
she said down by the by you you've been
fucking oh god look oh there's flecks of
it looks like you've been sitting on
bayou dicks girl this is not good
stop it i'm like the harder i try to
make this work than with this
oh i think it's working i think this is
working oh shit people want to know
there's a mirror see pet nose a mirror
on the floor
yeah you're kicking people oh it's so
bad
so bad i hate myself
now look at your teeth smile and turn to
the side joker what is that
how have you got it it wasn't this bad
it was oh it was like
oh i didn't see i would have said
something if it were this bad oh my god
i thought there was booger or stinky
sauce residue jelly beans you thought a
jelly bean did that i didn't think
jelly bean didn't look like yeah we are
airing this we're airing
all of this and i want everyone to know
that you guys did not tell me
i didn't tell you
20 minutes in no i saw a hint of tinge
of green
it's on your lips yeah i didn't notice
the teeth i look insane
i look but only like the bog of eternal
stench
that is such a good reference thank you
well
not that deep something thank you oh um
do you want to you want to fix it here
you want toothpaste thanks
it could be blueberry so oh that's a
toothpaste
it's a jelly bean that is toothpaste
jelly bean does that count as brushing
your teeth
it tastes exactly like toothpaste yeah
so love
um i'm in love you guys i said i love
you to a man
um details it was not easy
so i'm really big on for him to be there
when you said it
for me to hashtag it so i can get a paid
partnership um
no it was like a every kiss begins with
yeah so who wants to sponsor my uh
relationship
um i i'm really weird about the word
love
i don't know why i always ask the guest
what is your definition of love i'm
always
like i feel like we throw that word
around a lot um you weren't worried
about it when you made that special
you also you said at the end of every
podcast yeah i love you i love you
because we thought you know and i love
that amy letterman joke where it's like
when you're dating someone we say i love
you so much all the time now that's so
true
that by the time that she goes i love
you i love you love you lovely and then
the person you're dating you're like
love you love you love you love you
love you love you love you love you it's
like almost so true awkward
like that's that amy letterman joke of
like how you're saying i love you to
complete strangers
but i can't say to the person i'm in a
relationship with and i think for me i
was like i kind of want to protect this
word i wanted to get its
value back like i wanted to be like um
i like that we say love a lot you could
die tomorrow that's true
you know what i mean i think why are we
saving this word
like you don't mean it if i tell someone
i love them i genuinely mean it yeah
and if i say i love something in that
moment i probably do yeah
so i know why am i gonna keep what like
what am i saving it for yeah
so why am i like hoarding hoarding this
great thing i know and you see that this
is like
like um just the when someone
because i think i love you has been used
as a way to manipulate for me
so much you know like i love you i love
you like you know when people do it like
oh yeah i said i love you to someone it
was they say it back
that that one time a guy
said um i love you to me and i panicked
and i said thank you
you have to finish the story you're
telling me didn't they say it back
no what is the story no he has no oh
he's if this was the notebook it would
never have been a good film i've
filmed film the sound is fail i swear to
god
uh my no this the dude that i'm with
we have he has said i love you before
and i said i don't say that
i say when i'm really really ready
because i think sometimes when you're
healthy
because sometimes when you say that word
too soon then you
for me personally you kind of put
yourself you're like well i'm in love
with this person now
we said that word now have passed this
now we have to keep saying that person
like you haven't talked about having a
love or multiple episodes
i know because i'm in denial about um uh
being in a relationship and i have
intimacy issues benton you know this
i like do you wanna work on it now yeah
i think the other day someone was like
how long have you two been together
he said a year and i said two weeks
well like at the same time there's
reality in fantasy
so i'm like i've got my internal clock
but i just think the
the i love you i just want some things
to be special where did you say it
when did you say it um i think it was
with words
i wanted to sign language i wanted to be
special
let me show you the text you said in a
text
no i've said it before there's not
there's i haven't prepared a story or
anything it's like
we've been dating for a while two weeks
he thinks a year i think two weeks again
again i thought this was going to be the
thing i never knock over
um i love the idea of you starting a
story that you can't finish which i love
you at a wedding being like did you
think you'd never knock that over
the weight distribution oh that's a
really cute cup
thank you i love it i love you keep
going um
so i love you like i say i love you to
literally everyone i have it on my cup
so
i should just turn the cup towards them
totally i say i love you to everyone
i have a special called i love you i
have posters officially i'm your
girlfriend
i'm your girlfriend yeah that's very a
lot of hints being thrown out i like to
make very confrontational
um uh it's explained though you're dm's
people like no we are together
um and uh and i just i'm really stingy
about it in real life because i think
when i was a kid it confused me when
people said i love you i love you but i
didn't feel
loved or something that's interesting i
think it got i conflated i love you with
like
i'm trying to manipulate you i love you
i thought it meant like calm down
oh you know what i'm saying like i think
that sometimes we use i love you
to go like i love you i love you i love
we use it at the wrong times and then we
build bad associations in our brains
so i'd like i just need to rewire my
associations with it
you know because it's like it was
weaponized i think when was the last
time it was weaponized statue though
um a couple years like
year and a half are you two years and
you can recognize it when that's
happening now
what's that i said lord yeah when
someone's like well i mean the
holidays are always you know go home to
family i love you
we're family but you know it's that kind
of thing my extended family does that
and i'm like we don't talk
it's like listen to what you're saying
and how you're saying it they don't
match
they're not congress at all but in the
south people are like if you're family
you're a family like there's no greater
bond there's
no love beyond this and it's like i feel
i don't i see you once a year
i don't even know your middle name linda
if i need a liver i'll let you know
i won't i'd rather go than to hear about
it
like if i if i need a blood pressure
call i mean that's really it it is it is
family is important when you need an
organ
i'm saving mine right now let's do one
last jelly
divine before i provide one last jelly
bean
[Applause]
oh my god was it tutti frutti we're
rolling right
um i want to i am super all over the
place on those podcasts as you can tell
no you
i mean but here's the thing this is i
the whole point of podcast is you're
able to be all over the place and there
are no rules
why would i what's the point otherwise
yeah oh putting out a quality product
yeah i think yeah i've heard about that
yeah letting it all flow together i
don't for one what
but yeah you're right it's your podcast
so this is fucking
this is literally because all my all my
guy friends that come on this podcast
and do it especially ones that are in
long relationships
they're like yeah no i do i do this for
women i'm fucking not ones that i'm i
don't have to do this
on my spare time yeah i get that
i don't have to try to follow a woman's
stream of consciousness insanity
if i'm not marrying her yeah so i
realize i'm pushing
there is a level of after i propose to
chloe just like uh
caring way less i yeah about about
anyone else
i'm like yeah i'm not gonna marry you so
yeah so i'm not gonna
fight with you or even have this it's
fine no i already picked the person i
fight with and it was you've done so
much with your hair
in the four minutes we've been recording
you put it down you mess it up you
flopped it over you teased it out and my
turn is it i'm trying to i'm flirting
yeah
is it not working that'd be cool if just
20 minutes in you go
by the way this is actually really kind
of amazing because it's clear
i'm not like whatever trying to beguile
you but
um i love that uh that the idea of as
soon as you get engaged
you can't see any woman as a sexual
object yeah again
like i'm literally putting my hair up
most guys are like you're just putting
her hair up like okay i
put her hair down you're just like what
are you doing it's a lie
like none of them you're moving like i
just
i love that that as soon as you get
engaged and all other women are off
limits you're like can you
all girls are just a bro like i'm just
obsessed with that idea
yeah we're broken down like can you stop
doing anything you're doing so we can
fucking finish this
like there's so we can finish this
because all guys have
like like there's just there's always
like a certain like
we're gonna kind of flirt and it's like
like i i just love
when my guy friends get engaged and they
change
yeah yeah i wonder if that happened i'm
sure it did do a point i well
to the fact that uh yeah you just aren't
looking at anyone
in a sexual way and even if you are
you're going like
don't don't you dare think that you
fucking animals
yeah god piece of shit like that's so
yeah because it's like yeah it's like my
friends say they'll they're like they'll
see it and then there's
nope like just don't don't just don't
well that's because then if you
are then you're like this marriage is
doomed don't do it
get out bail healthy it's healthy like
yeah well it's healthy to be like
a galuga and then move it along
it's healthy just like when a guy makes
cartoon noises
steam steam and then keep it moving you
can't dwell on it too much
how long were you with chloe before you
got engaged uh
five years hmm is that right
i might have got that rushing down the
altar over here
you guys i think it's good that you
waited because i was like i think you're
gonna i think you're actually gonna be
together forever
and i think if you got engaged to since
you're asking my opinion on your
relationship
um uh i feel like if you got engaged too
soon it probably wouldn't have i think
that's right do you think
of course yeah and then how did you do
it
how did i propose uh i was
uh i we have like this little boat
and uh it goes next to the other boat
it looks inside the big boat that i told
you from one boat to the other boat it's
like a little it's about newport beach
and we have this little bow and it's
like a
electric boat so we have this little
electric boat
and i woke up that morning and
uh was had planned on give your gun
ready because i'm about to interrupt a
lot yeah
i just i'm thinking i'm obsessed with
proposals because my brain is going if
you could come to me
and we're like whitney i'm gonna go do
this on a boat here's my plan i would
have given you
obviously cause i would have gone if a
guy proposed me on a boat
if i didn't want to say yes i'd just
jump off like i worried that i would
panic
but i mean i would want you to swim to
shore if you said no
you know what i mean like if you're
going to say no to me swing your ass to
shore
you're like you're like okay the shore's
about a mile yeah this is enough to kill
her if she says no
she's gonna really want to live right
here single
like how do you but do you decide like
i'm gonna do the beginning i'm gonna do
the end
well it was a very i had planned it this
weekend it was kind of the only weekend
that it was kind of really gonna work
and i woke up like with all this energy
and i like to sleep in you know and no i
don't
well you don't know but i know and i'm
telling you
no but i think that's fascinating do you
sleep late i think of you some of this
other like five
no i stay up late and then i sleep later
but uh so i was up like two hours before
her and she rolls over and i'm just like
like scared like just and she's like huh
uh hi and i'm like good morning
and she was like oh like pretty weirded
out yeah like
i would go what did you do yeah and i
kept saying i was just like had so much
nervous energy that i kept saying
uh it's good today's gonna be the best
day god today's gonna rock
today's gonna be awesome you send it to
her yeah like a fucking
what are you fucking weird weirdo
and so she's like okay and i'm like uh
let's
go uh get breakfast and so we take the
little boat because it's
cute as shit where i live and where uh
take the little boat out and then
uh i asked her to drive which i never
ever do
since women can't they can't it's just
they just can't it's not
and she's saying i can't they
uh but so she's like weird and then i
turned around and then
and dropped to well why would you ask
her to drive because you were like
because
i couldn't get on a knee and drive the
boat
so i was like i turn around
and drop on a knee and ask her
and then had a speech like a full-on
minute and a half of me saying
shit that neither of us can remember
like
i i was like i knew i was like
you know i'm in an improv improv
something sweet as fuck
in the moment and then it'll be good
and uh neither of us can remember like
we both just sort of blacked out and
we're like
by the way cut to like some random ring
camera footage that did get it and it's
you're like doing your stand-up yeah
it's just me you're just going to
autopilot anyway
so where are you guys from that's funny
you get down one news who are you
so where are you from you know louisiana
you know what you visited my grandma you
didn't crowd
yeah my proposal um yeah and then
we yeah and then we were engaged so what
was okay i want to break down this
because i'm fascinated by
guys i feel like guys like proposing
secretly
because it's your only opportunity
hey let me shit on this setup right away
no didn't like it it was an exciting
thing
and i lean back
because it's like the only time a guy
gets to like
be like a spy for like because you're
like hiding the ring it's like a heist
like
you have a jewel like you get
jamie yeah i guess i never do it it's
like you guys have to hide a jewel it's
like the closest you'll ever be to
a fucking jewel thief you're like a
james bond movie yeah
um the way guys describe it when you
asked them about the republic you this
was actually the sanest
recollection of a proposal i don't know
why i didn't give you the whole cause
guys are
trying to get out of here no you can't
you're gonna you're gonna take me six
and a half hours to drive home
bump you have to stay for four hours
or i will not air it i did hide the uh i
just was like what's my leverage i was
like
you drove out of here for nothing
uh i did hide it in a shoe and she
you know you know you know chicks right
bro to bro
yeah you know chicks yeah they organize
your stuff
and they fit make things better steal
your money
they don't really love you for you they
just take your money that's a deeper
issue that you have
and they don't really love you for you
that's something else that i think you
need to talk to somebody else about
because i'm not qualified and then
uh so i hid that in a shoe and she
fully reorganized she i came home and
all my stuff was
like rearranged and like color
coordinated and like
the boots are with blue the shoes were
upside down and they had been she shaken
out
and i feel like girls know i just hear
the girls like
no not because we're so sudden finish
it's actually more unsettling when it
goes up to the scene
i didn't know what the hell just
happened i thought we were under siege
that's good i like that this is a new
element you're enjoying it
yeah you know how ellen pranks her guess
my staff pranks me that's
pretty cool okay so the shoes were boots
with their boots
hey thank you you're fired so anyway my
bit
it's just going to get worse and worse
it's going to be it's a pellet gun next
time you're like oh
it's a salt pellet that would hit me
i'm getting out benton
it was a tick tock it was a fun tick
tock video but you know what is i feel
like we never like get to really hang
out and i'm very excited to talk to you
i'm excited too
um so get this shoe clearly
and uh so she rearranged everything i
was convinced she thought that but i had
i bought the ring
like two months so she moved a shoe that
the ring was in
without knowing it without knowing it
what shoe did you pick i love this shit
i picked a uh there were two different
shoes because i got
weird about where i was hiding in at
first the fact that you didn't put it
like a gopro
to film you picking a shoot like that's
my favorite i
picked a boot cause i figured like you
were you're really gonna have to get in
a boot like a van
i was like you're gonna see it's gonna
look lumpy on the outside so i got like
a boot
it was these it was these actually oh in
your shoes oh my shoes okay okay okay
they're not her shoes okay because that
would have been i was like that is
wildly dumb oh yeah it's like it's like
a little
slip how small is this ring
that is a female shoe a slip
right let's talk about um how we're
gonna
keep chloe uh married to you what did
you do for valentine's day
uh dinner mm-hmm yeah and then
what about um uh okay
did you make it or did you make it no we
went to a restaurant
yes outdoors come on grab hoax
um what is uh uh i wanna hear the rest
of the
proposal cause i find that guys when
they tell the story they normally go
well can i say that she found out
she knew about it so she didn't find it
in the shoe
but weirdly i had proposed and there was
like a two-month span where i had the
ring
and every weekend we just had something
and i was working a lot during that time
and i'm like i finally had a weekend
where like this
can be our weekend and i'll do it then
and so like there was a lot of pressure
on that weekend
she the night before this is her story
i'm like maybe she just sniffs around my
shit
all the time and is constantly like
looking through stuff but the night
before
she gets it was my birthday in a few
weeks and so she
was wanting to get me the same exact
backpack that i have because i
really like the backpack i just want the
a new one and
uh she was like digging through to find
the make and model
of the backpack
likely story and she found the receipt
so like after i proposed like uh after
we're all basking in the glow of our
love
a like two days later or something maybe
then maybe the next day
she was like so um how much did it cost
the ring like just in ballpark and cubic
zirconias are not
cheap anymore i told her because she
found the receipt
for the deposit which is you have to pay
half
to have them go get and fit it and
everything and then half on the
so i told her and she's like hmm
she thought i was lying like i got which
would have been a great deal on this
ring by the way but she was like hmm
and i'm like what that's a that's a lot
of money what do you mean that's a very
nice ring
like and she's like no no that is it's
very nice and i'm like so you think she
hears the full knows the full amount she
hears the half amount that's still funny
yeah and i told her
the full amount so she was like and then
it took like an
hour of me like why are you being weird
it's such a weird thing to lie about too
yeah like why
like you know how much i make you know
like why would i also just
like the first order of business as like
a husband and wife is me being bad with
money
yep you know and bragging about it
actually i don't think i watched
actually uh overpaid for that shiny rock
that you wear on your finger
yeah by the way it's actually like the
truth is probably worse
yeah yeah for sure like i'm in a place
where i'm like
if you had said the full price i've been
like are you fucking crazy
now i have to work forever we could have
saved that and just fucking
moved to martha texas oh
martha i love marfa so what happens when
you
get in it's been five years you get
engaged it's like
how soon are we doing is that like
what's the car like
well then covid struck so then it was we
couldn't get married anywhere great time
to be a monogamous you can't cheat
yeah perfect time perfect time i was
like
thank god i locked it down okay we need
to stop this podcast because adam's
probably being hilariously funny
and i'm getting jealous so let's talk
about something else
let's literally interrupt the entire
show not just the conversation
adam's being too funny do you guys like
magicspan can i tell you something
this started as just an ad and now i eat
magic spoon i'm not even joking there is
so much magic spoon at your house
there's so much magic nobody's like
we could build another house out of it
that's a good idea it's
literally so many boxes i go through
them so fast
and i eat them at night well if you stop
covering your whole body and then you
wouldn't go through them so fast
well look how else am i make money on
only fans
don't go searching for that it doesn't
exist the magic spoon is great there's
zero sugar 12 grams of protein and only
three net carbs in each serving
and so many of you have asked that
finally now on this very damn day
you can build your own custom the the
the shakedown
the octopus on the cover is enough to
buy and look sorry last thing
there's games on the back they don't do
that remember when you were a kid and
you play the games on the back of the
box thank you magic spoon they also do
that sorry about it they do that
if you if you if you want delicious
child like cereal for grown ups magic
spoon is for you but you can
you can put together that's on the side
of the box yeah yeah i know you said it
so fast there's
literally you can build your own variety
custom box now you can choose between
the cocoa flavor the fruity flavor the
frosted the blueberry
plus some brand new flavors like peanut
butter and cinnamon
since when i mix it it's keto friendly
gluten-free
free soy free low carb and gmo free it's
so free
just gotta pay for it go to
magispoon.comwhitney to grab a variety
pack and try today and be sure to use
our promo code whitney at checkout to
save five dollars off your order and
magic spoon is so confident in their
product it's backed with a 100
happiness guarantee so if you don't like
it for any reason they'll refund you
your money no questions asked
that's magicspoon.com whitney and use
the code whitney to save five dollars
off
we thank you magic spoon for sponsoring
our podcast
i'm re-decorating my entire house
renovating my entire house
we had article as a sponsor remember we
got that
furniture outside the loungers so cute
and now i'm looking for furniture and i
don't like anything else
my whole house is almost furnished by
article i love it it's so it's like
it just doesn't go out of stock it's
just like so classic it
goes with anything it looks like i have
tv money but i don't
and that's what i like about it and you
know what else everything kind of
matches i can't match things so
everything on there if you put them in a
room they all work it's weird someone's
like who dick or this room you're like
me knee on nyquil at 2 am article is
amazing
rugs couch every i mean everything is
good article combines the
curation of a boutique furniture shop
with the comfort and simplicity of
shopping online
because you know like that's incredible
i'm not naming names but there's a
couple stores right now where i'm like
who do you think you are
charging mm-hmm fifteen hundred dollars
not article fast affordable shipping is
available across the us and canada
and it's free on orders over 999
dole here wow how would you describe it
just go to the website like it's like i
want to get a love seat for the new nook
from there
guess what i know where to get it yeah
article.com go there buy it it's fun
support the sponsor supports us that's
good to remember article is offering our
listeners 50
off your first purchase of 100 or more
go to article.com
whitney and the discount will be
automatically applied at checkout that's
article.com
whitney to get 50 off your first
purchase of 100 doll hairs or more
this isn't in the ad copy but i'm better
at reading them than benton don't you
think
um i think sometimes this isn't in the
eye honestly i think i should stop
talking for the rest of the month you
did take a
beat after article.com because i read it
as i
read that as go to article.com whitney
the discount and i'm like what i thought
you were containing your rage that it
was invented
you're like no i don't care when you say
doll hairs i
doubt it's so funny i think rupaul made
that up i'm gonna have the
worst gut bomb by the end of like i
chose she has like a
a beverage refrigerator and she's like
grab whatever you want and i'm like
i'll take you up on that so i got
elderflower
press
water obviously cold brew coffee with
almond milk
perrier fusions and a coke zero that
i've already finished
this is the worst concoction of
especially for a long drive home
oh yeah for like you brought five over
so hey chloe
not afraid of commitment at all
i need my flavors i need my tastes
he's committed in one place so now i i
do feel like though when i was engaged
i had made such a big commitment that
everything else was like i don't know i
want to try all of them like everywhere
else in life
like i normally love chocolate and i'm
like i'll try uh you know cookie dough
and oreo like i
like i'm not monogamous in any other
part of my family i'm gonna get a new
hair person
like when i was when i was first
like you know like a new hair cutter you
know it's like because we're in all
these monogamous relationships
and then when that one happened i had to
like go like okay now i need to
cheat on someone else just to get to not
feel silly
yeah so pinned down she'd hurt someone
i would just hire a guy to stab him
um the guy that came to your house and
asked for my mom
asked for oh what was that we have a
couple weird things in our past
yes we have a weird friend i think we
should be better friends
for sure and i think that now the time
is now
i think the time is now oh because i'm a
good fuck it
i'm a good fr tell chloe i'm a good
friend i think you are
for your husband to have that's a
platonic girlfriend yeah
because i will basically do the dirty
work of the girl when she's not around
so i will be chloe when chloe's not
around i'll go who the fuck who's that
why is she texting you
sure like i'm the snitch that will
that cool yeah let's definitely hang out
more
[Laughter]
seems fun
two wives two wives none of the benefits
no but it's like it's like who's that
i'm telling chloe
don't isn't it that's my sister isn't it
well she should know
that you put a smiley face but
don't you feel like once you all because
my guy friends i have so many platonic
guy friends and when they get in a
serious relationship i always feel like
i know like she's just like not gonna
want me to be or you know what i mean
it's like
it's just like a natural thing where you
stop being able to hang out with your
platonic girlfriends as
much you know and uh i get very
excited um to be friends with my friends
wives
well all right welcome in so chloe loves
you i love you i thought you're doing it
she just isn't she likes you as a person
hates just your whole life
she's not a fan of yours just not a fan
of you of your work of your comedy
of of your work but again
uh of what you consider talent
do you she watches you with a sound off
what are you going to do about the
wedding are you are you involved are you
kind of like you have to
be the center of attention all the time
and you don't want to deal uh
yeah i'm not that involved i i just like
tried a bunch of cakes and shit and that
was about that was cool
i was like yeah actually it was like a
lot it was like all day thing of like
tasting little treats i don't see any
women jumping out of it
uh when they jump out at the end it was
a lot of just like
sitting and eating and talking about
like every little
and some like and chloe that aren't
delicious i'm confused
i don't like cake so i'm like everyone
i'm like this is fine
whatever cake whatever cake
i don't think it's that out of pocket to
not like cake i don't like cake
okay there's five people in this room
two of them out the gate don't like cake
pat
i like cake yeah because you're not a
psychopath i like
more i like pie more too i like pie more
i like pie more
see you whitney
you immediately pitch pot podcast
um uh it's number one it's uh it's
beating rogan it's crazy
it's already done or whatever random
it's always like the top podcast or like
whatever i'm just leaving you started
now like what if you just started
filming it's like
joe rogan and then there's always two or
three like spy
or like murder podcasts that i've never
heard of that are like actually
yeah it's the number one and you're like
oh i don't i have no idea
never heard of it never heard of it it's
20 million
so 20 million downloads of a uh uh
podcast about murder and rape and all
this sort of stuff and if i
make one joke where i like make fun of
rose mcgowan i go to jail
it's just sort of like ugh it's so weird
when i look at like um
what's what go to jail
you know what i mean comedy jail yeah
i would go to culture jail i hate
twitter twitter's like
that's and i'm starting to dislike
instagram i used to be like fully on
board with both
and then now i posted i got to meet joe
biden i did a few things with joe biden
and uh i posted like a photo of me like
shaking his hand and being like
hey i'm not that political but i met
this guy a few times
i hope he's gonna be a great president
uh
and then people are like
and you're like jesus was that good for
sound
[Laughter]
i love cake i like pie i like pie more
than cake
it's just ringing
so i'm just like the the fervor pitch on
like the internet now is just so
high that i'm just i'm kind of steering
clear for a little bit i'm gonna send
you something
because it blew my mind and
uh kelly clarkson posted something about
meeting biden
and the comments i did i did a
two-minute screen record
of the comments because i was so
incredulous and
shocked okay thank you for
explaining what incredulous was because
i was like
and shocked and incredulous just for the
viewers at home incredible if i'm
incredible
you are just so just
grumpy and just sort of like
like kind of i remember the first time i
saw you do stand up the improv
do tell okay no do you want to did you
see me would you remember
me i knew i feel like i knew who you
were
already before and then i remember the
first time you saw me because you came
up and you're like
how do i know you dude i remember the
first time i saw you i'm like i don't
know
i was so shocked you were so fucking
funny
so soon like i was like i didn't
you have this i've been doing stand-up
for 12 years at that point
look i guess okay so you finally caught
my attention
so congratulations you knew you for a
near decade by the time you were
together that's not true okay i was like
fuck
um because i remember seeing you at the
improv and you i was like so
jealous like i've i've always been
jealous of you because you have this
like
natural like you're just so fucking
funny even when you're just like not
talk it's just so annoying
thanks i'm not trying to i'm trying to
hurt you and it's i'm hurting myself
um but it's like i'm doing a lot of
weird tongue comedy right now i keep
catching myself be like
but you should do like a quick splice
together for this hour conversation of
me just going
we're gonna be in debit can you stop
licking the bike thank you
who's up next chloe's a lucky lady
jesus that's right right
um no but like it was just so obvious
that you were gonna be so successful it
was so
obvious and then i remember you getting
so successful
and being like i'm glad it was obvious
to you because i don't think it was a
lot obvious to a lot of other people
especially at the improv because i
worked there i was a door guy there
i had no idea yeah and i i worked there
for like two years
and then when i started to get like i
got the montreal comedy festival
when i was working there so like i i
came back and then
rita the manager was like actually an
executive from nbc was like
do you work here and i'm like yeah and
they're like i just saw you at montreal
and i'm like uh-huh and he goes you
can't work here anymore you have to quit
go work in the valley
i understand you have to make money but
you cannot work here and then i go
upstairs to tell rita the manager of the
hollywood improv and she's like yeah
that's right peeps you can't work here i
was waiting for you to quit get out of
here and i'm like fuck
uh and then other and then the other
like guys that worked at the improv that
were also comics and like
just people at that level were like you
you got montreal whose dick did you suck
what the fuck man like actively mad at
me and i'm like i'm sorry i didn't
i didn't mean to i tried to fuck it up i
really did
i saw you and i was like he's gonna be
so fucking successful and then you get
your show and it starts to be a thing
and i remember going like
who the fuck is telling him how to be a
boss like who
who teaches comedians these things
because i was like doing something i had
no idea how to be a boss no one teaches
you that and then all of a sudden you
have to like
be in charge of people and you're so
young
and there's so many people that like are
like at 25 like i want to run a business
and be a mogul it's like
you you have to have people you have to
be able to like say no to
50 people that already hate you every
day it was weird because we were
25 i was 25 when i got the show so
i that's so wild yeah i was yeah
and but at the time you're like no this
is the right age for it to happen
you know yeah this is about right my
tools
why didn't it take so long yeah exactly
i mean exactly
i got my cannabis drink i got there when
i was 18 so like at that point that's
seven years in you're like
yeah i'm coming up on a decade that's
about right
uh but yeah it was weird and i'm sure
you went through the same thing of like
having to tell like grown men that this
is what we're doing for the day
and you're like okay so uh so this is
the scene where this we're shooting so
you've been in a war
right well i'm going to tell you how to
live like it's like it's so weird like
we were smart we well not we weren't
smart we were fucking idiots but we
uh comedy central told us that they're
like
we're giving you the show it's your show
you created it
uh you're the executive producers but
you have to hire a showrunner
so we hired kevin etten who had already
written on some shows and he was like
he wasn't old he was like 30 you know
so so he was our show runner and uh
you know and so he helped so like can
you
deliver the news it's important i think
there's this thing where it's like i
don't know if you're
hiring like young younger people at all
in any of your business but there is
like a little
bit of a um
like i can't give you this news or
something like i need someone else to
give you this news like this is the
first time in my
my life i'm like scared that like i feel
like i've worked so hard to be able to
be
direct and clear and not emotional an
adult and a boss and now
i feel like if i'm directing clear i'm
gonna like get sent to hr
for sure yeah don't be convoluted and
enjoy it write little notes and they're
like um
she wrote me half a note she ripped it
in half it was a love note it was a
valentine's day card is that weird i
mean
i'm just trying to not go to hr yeah
things weird she goes make this make
sense yeah i just made you like a custom
little gift with it
is that so i just don't want to be
uncomfortable yeah and it's just her
lunch order i don't know why this is
such a big do you feel
scared when you're on sets i was on a
set yesterday and everyone was like no
i just don't want to there was the covet
but there's a lot of like
it was a it was a scene it was a show
there was two shows i've done so far
where it's like a guest spot where they
want me to be
someone who's being sexually like like
harassed in a comedy
for the show it's in the script i
already know exactly what's happening
and people are like are you okay you're
like are you okay i'm like no i saw in
the script that's what i was doing yeah
i agreed to this
yeah i'm a comedian this is literally
the least rapey day i've had
in 15 years and then but they're like
there's this i i guess i'm calling it an
overcorrection just because it's what i
have personally seen
i'm not saying it is like in the
zeitgeist but like people are actually
women are
gonna just sue you at all times and are
so fragile and i'm just like oh
like this is not good either yeah
you guys shouldn't be scared of me
that's crazy uh it's like the pendulum
swing of like
it was so like everything went and then
now we're way over here and then
but but they're like it's just like i
don't know just like it made me it made
me so mad because it's like
a set and i've been on your set uh
before it's like it has to be so
fun for everything to be funny and it's
like everyone's in so much fear
of fucking around and i just am like ugh
it's like the safe comedy thing is just
so bizarre
that sucks i'm about to go back and
shoot the righteous gemstones and i
i thought you know i'm about to go back
home so thank you
wow i was like damn um
thank you honestly the best segues are
compliments
uh yeah i'm about to go shoot the right
gemstones in south carolina and i'm like
i hope to god it's not like that i don't
think so though no no no no i think
just because we're like yeah
you know and it's like here this is the
epi epicenter of
the metoo movement and all you know and
no it's people are scared here
it's the epicenter of the people who
have been the grossest
for sure it's the epicenter of the
guilty people yes i'm saying
yes you go to others like
it's popular here to like out woke each
other
to be like the most and if you're not
then
you're the problem to me like the wokest
people the people i'm most impressed
with are like
yeah i wore some fucking sketchy
halloween costumes uh in my 20s
i i didn't realize that yeah but
do you look at those halloween are you
embarrassed by them or are you like
show one that's not great oh sure yeah
yeah
yeah it's not i mean yeah my my
blackface years
were by the time i by the time i
perfected blackface i wasn't allowed to
do anything
my publicist was going to call me on the
drive home from this podcast and go i
don't know i just got a
tingling sensation that you said
something i just got bell's palsy um
no here's the deal with podcasting i'm
finding because i want to talk about
um your podcast and why comedians are
doing it and why we're all doing it and
why
they work and why if they don't like i
think if you have a podcast
going on other shows that are not
podcasts i have fine does not matter at
all that
like going on like late night shows it
was it was after i did
uh dax shepard's podcast
and i got more of a response
than i did the tonight show like in the
same week and it got more of the a
response
from doing dax's show than i did doing
the tonight show which
as a comedian you're like that's the
show that's the biggest show
that your entire life you're like oh my
god tonight show tonight's show or like
letterman or just doing the big
you're like this is gonna be the the
thing and then
i did dax's show and it was just huge
and i was like oh we should start a
podcast
but they're also the difference between
someone watching you for 10 minutes
and like three hours you know what i
mean it's sort of like
you know it's it's such a different kind
of um
investment you know so it's like coming
on podcasts i find like make such a big
difference when someone's starting a
podcast because it's like a different
kind of listener
for sure you know and i feel like people
that listen to comedy podcasts
specifically
want to hang out with comedians but then
they don't live in a place where there's
many comedians
no so they're like yeah i just listen
these guys you mean hollywood or
prison or rehab prison what are you
talking about
they don't have comedians around yeah
because they're all here or with the fbi
uh in a waiting room somewhere um i know
it's been
what do you make of all that i'm too i'm
two beverages down over here
do you because i feel like you have this
ability to like
i mean you kind of i feel like you just
kind of became a movie star like
like kind of i was a decadent
uh when it happened it didn't happen
overnight i know but what but you
thank you for saying movie star that
makes you feel really good you are a
movie star i mean the movie business
doesn't matter as much as you did but
you're a movie sir
no i have started i have started movies
yeah no i've gotten in like arguments
with my family where they're like
my dad's like well you're not a movie
star and i'm like
so who is that who is i have starred in
movies so techn technically
i i technically i am but i see what
you're saying he's like just
yeah but not a movie star movie star and
i'm like you just said it twice though
but
so now where are we you just said it
twice but it
that is why you're funny i just learned
why you're so funny you've been
emotionally abused
i feel so much better now because i was
like why is he so funny that's why your
dad hates you
yeah yeah you're describing abuse
betterhelp.com we got you a free
daddy
stupid love me daddy
i think it's safe to say that i'm
peeking
just in life when you say that i've i
peeked
but before we wait
i think it's fair to say that we go back
up a little bit there's green up there
this episode is brought to you by peek a
super advanced plant-based supplement
company
pete combines the finest ingredients
with cutting egg technology
to create ultra cutting edge oh there's
a cutting egg
this episode is brought to you by peek a
super advanced plant-based supplement
company
peak combines the finest ingredients
with cutting edge technology to create
ultra effective and high quality
supplements i have to read it again
this episode is brought to you by peek a
super advanced plant-based supplement
company
pete combines the finest ingredients
with cutting edge technology to create
ultra effective and high quality
supplements for your body
for your body i was just about to prank
you by touching your leg under the table
i can see
are you absorbing all your vitamin c's
are you just pissing it out
oh this is i was like um because studies
have sound that you absorb much less
than 50 of vitamin c when you consume
amounts greater than a hundred thousand
milligrams mega grams worth of megagrams
megagrams
okay you know what let me step in here
daily immune maximize for absorption
with
liposomal encapsulation technology
revolutionary formula supports a healthy
immune system's cellular health healthy
collagen levels and healthy aging
a powerful and absorbable vitamin c that
tastes amazing fits in your pocket and
you can squeeze into your mouth
no glass water or spoon needed naturally
delicious with just seven ingredients
no preservatives oh my god i thought it
was a slingshot
no no preservatives did you hear that
refined sugars or additives
i love them i carry them around whenever
you travel because you can mix them in
cold water
or if you're at the hotel you need hot
water some caffeine i put them in like
you put them in your gatorade yes i put
them in other drinks
oh okay well go to peak tea they're
delicious on their own as well
i know but i'm just saying i like when
you're like i need more caffeine in this
and i'll just throw it in when i'm like
on the right yes and i love those
options there's some
caffeine some without some you can snort
everything is crazy
seven clean ingredients go to peakt.com
whitney and use code whitney at checkout
to get five percent off your first order
plus free shipping when you purchase a
bundle
there's a reason pique has over 15 000
five-star reviews try it for yourself
risk-free with their 30-day satisfaction
guaranteed
you either love it or you get your money
back daily immune is flying off the
shelves people are ordering all around
daily immune is flying off the shelves
people are ordering two or more so stock
up quick
that's peaktee.com spelled p-i-q-u-e
that's peak.com that's oh that's
peaktee.com spelled p-i-q-u-e-t-e-a
dot com slash whitney and use code
whitney for five percent off
plus free shipping on a bundle good
packaging and by the way turmeric good
for inflammation
very good for inflammation lucy lucy
lucy what's that from lucy
lucy seinfeld
um you guys this um we don't have mic
stands because we re
purpose just refurbished you would have
noticed in the last three ads as well
but we're going to talk about it
and if you watch though if you watch
right now
no i wasn't i didn't talk in the last
class but they could see
yeah maybe so i'm holding the microphone
right now it looks insane
and i'm going to read this without
making any mistakes
thank you for thinking the dicks that
i'm around i need two hands benton
benton i'm like this he's like why are
you holding a dick i'm like that i'm
is a nicotine company founded by caltech
scientists and former smokers looking
for a better
cleaner nicotine alternative i made
through one sentence i feel like i
should get some kind of award finally
here's the horse
thank you finally alternatives that
don't suck
researched and developed for three years
to be made for people not patients lucy
has created nicotine gum with four
milligrams of nicotine that comes in
three flavors winter green cinnamon
pomegranate yum
those were like the um pinkberry flavors
i think
lucy also has a lozenge with four
milligrams of nicotine in cherry ice
flavor each and every flavor
actually tastes great um now that i can
finally taste it again can't wait it's
uh convenient discreet products can be
enjoyed anywhere flights work
on the go or even in the gym even when
you're doing your sensuals
we had a good friend that used uh bobby
lee uses
these in life yeah he's always seen
alternatives yes and his breath smells
way
better than it used to cinnamon it's 20
get rid of your cigarettes unplug your
vape throw out your dip
get some lucy nicotine gum or
lozenges this is a real deal a
subscription to lucy comes directly to
your door
each month it's so simple you don't have
to leave your house because lucy has
delivery down good view listeners go to
lucy.co and use promo code
to get 20 off all products on your first
order including gum or lozenges that's
lucy
dot co and use promo code whitney to
check out also
i have to give you this disclaimer
warning this product contains nicotine
derived from tobacco nicotine is an
addictive chemical
lucy dot co go there
and be sure to use that promo code
whitney
but didn't you don't you find though
like i don't know there's something um
i don't know there's something creepy
about the movie business i'm finding
i don't know i'm sure yes
for sure i mean i've had like old-timey
producers say some of the
craziest things to me like just be like
you want your dick sucked tonight i
could make that happen i could make a
call get your dicks up tonight and i'm
like
oh i'm good i'm good it was like to do
to do a movie that i'm just not gonna do
and they're like but there's also to
spice up the
deal they're like does he want his dick
sucked but there's also something funny
of like i'm like oh
but like it's uh there's also something
like i mean yes i guess
i do what but it's also like the fact
that you're offering the
me a leading movie means i can already
get that whenever i want
for sure it's it's something weird in
old-timey hollywood
and it's also like buy who i know like
who are they sending
who it's like old-timey hollywood where
they're like
yeah and you just imagine them like all
slicked back and like driving their
yeah in a time where ex-girlfriends are
canceling
of three years in a relationship or
cancelling matters like hey you want a
future allegation
for sure even even if like i was
ever creepy now i'm like i will i would
never be creepy
pick up some horse no no no no no did
anyone catch that
no thank you hey and i'm live streaming
this
oh no i was just twitch touch me live i
would not like to go to the strip club
thank you sir
thank you sir terrifying yeah you can't
do that like that's such a crazy
it's just a testament to how weird it's
been and i think what i realized like
like on shows there's like you're
together for a long
time movies by the time you've shot like
two weeks since you witnessed something
really bad happening you're like that's
only two more weeks like what am i gonna
what are we gonna stop like it's it's
almost like the machine is moving
and the train is moving too fast to to
address anything crazy
like you can't you know yeah i could see
that because yeah like by the
by the time but that's what's so people
realize what's going on they move for
sure
like that yeah if something crazy
happens it should be addressed
but i do like uh movies and how quick
that
because you could go into something and
it just sucks and you're like
oh the people suck like people are rude
or whatever it is
and you can just muscle it out and go
like okay and it'll be done in four
weeks or however find someone on the
subject yeah you'll like some people
but i mean for the most part i've liked
every production i've been on before
before we came on the podcast
yeah i gave you exactly like data
mcbride you hated
anna kendrick and that she was a monster
and like was like like and um
that i'm the only person you've ever
enjoyed working with but whatever you
need to do to get your package off the
ground
this is important on ihot radio podcast
i want to ask you because i feel like
there was like you you were just
in literally a movie a month like at
like start like starting
on tv like two three tv shows at once
but i mean at least do the one you're
investing in
you are you gay i gave them you a four
pack
drink can drink can uh you know i prefer
perrier
buddy to work on your business skills
um but i uh was there anything that you
came really close on that you
really really wanted and didn't get uh
no got everything i've ever wanted
you're like don't know what that's like
uh no there's been there's been some
things where they're like
you're you're you're in talks or they
you're on the shortlist
and and then you're you never really
know how close
you actually were yeah yeah yeah or
something you passed on
that you're like i shouldn't have passed
on a fucking it was big it's like sandra
bullock passed on a million dollar baby
i love stories like that yeah which is
you can't imagine any other way but
you're sort of like oh is she like
kicking her no but there's been like
uh there's been
movies that for sure and i'm not gonna
name it but for sure they're going to
suck
and i did not want it and they came to
me
uh and i it was like hey you're in the
running for this
and it will be a lot of money it's a big
studio movie
and you'll be the lead of it uh but it's
for sure gonna be bad
like without a doubt i'm like oh it's
gonna be bad and i'm like
i don't want it that's so stupid i would
never do that in a million years how
much money exactly
but i'm not gonna do it even if they
offer it to me and then they didn't
offer it to me and then i'm like
i wish i did i wish i could have gotten
it yeah sure okay okay well i just got
passed around for a bad movie yeah huh
at the end of the day they passed on
they passed something in the record
books
no one cares no one that's all that just
the fucking score card
they're gonna say in the when when the
book comes out
adam
when i see someone that i feel like i
was up for something or passed on
me for something and i know and i see
them at like a thing
it's always like hey yeah yeah i was
yeah i was doing a thing and i wish i
could have worked out
like i pretend i passed and you know
what i mean
so embarrassing i i for modern family i
did like
25 episodes of modern family and they
we were gonna work out a deal for me to
come back and
uh and possibly marry sarah hyland's
character
and it didn't work out scheduling wise
and then they just decided like
we can't juggle all your schedule with
our schedule
and we're just going to kill the deal
and i wanted to do it i wanted to finish
out how famous you got
and then you were like on that show yeah
it's like
you can't really tell how when you're
getting more famous but it was so funny
to just be like oh adam devine's
starring in it oh he's not star this
he's just was because you were on it
before
right on modern family and uh
and then i run into steve levitan like
at some of one of those like
pre-emmy hollywood parties and
we talk for a few minutes very cold
cordial very nice like
we're very friendly he's a funny guy and
then i saw him like
the next night because you know how when
they had those parties there's like
eight it's all the same people yeah and
embarrassing when you have like network
with some of the night before and you
see him again you're like we did this
yeah totally and he's gonna make some
more connections steve goes literally
we're talking i'm all right go and i'm
like oh hey how's it going good to see
you again he goes
we just did this last night
and i'm he's like i'm going to go uh
grab a drink just do this
right now you're not coming back
no use for you we just did this you've
i've gotten what i've needed yeah
yes your work here is done i need to go
find an actor to marry sarah hyland
max greenfield where are you i mean it
really is like
it's because if this this business is so
incredibly inappropriate and i try to
tell you it's so much of it because so
much
of it is like guys does socializing but
it's really like hardcore like
networking yes and it's like someone
going like i'm doing
a drink that's that's them being like
she's prettier and thinner i'm gonna go
talk to her i'm gonna
yeah and you're just like that's
actually what it is but it's in under
this like
ruse that we're all like socializing and
like
like friends but they're those parties
are pretty fun though
they're fun when you're i'll say they're
they were fun
when i was when you win as much as you
win yeah
everyone just like like loves super nice
to you they're but they're thrown in my
honor
uh so what do you mean what parties are
you talking about i'm like oh okay
that's what we're talking about i
remember especially like the first few
years
of workaholics when like the show was
pretty
like red hot and we had no wherewithal
as to like how fancy the parties that we
were going to were or like
what's appropriate and what is not
appropriate those were the most fun
because we'd go there and just get drunk
and i arm wrestled the big guy from the
blind side
and then they found me all drunk in a
corner like cornering wesley snipes
being like who won that like how was
prison and they're like adam we've got
to go
you don't pay your taxes you're just
like what
yeah totally and and i like i saw chris
hemsworth and i i evidently i was going
like he's not even that big
he's like you called this guy thor and
because you were just with the guy from
the blind side comparatively he's a tiny
small man that's so and those parties
were so fun
and then now you know now it would be
like because i'm in my
when it's when you're 25 doing that
people are like
those guys are so fun you know what look
at them go
they're so grateful they're just happy
to be they're just having a great time
but now
like i'm in my mid-30s there would be
like he's embarrassing this is
embarrassing
yeah it'd be like we should call someone
yeah for sure does he need help
okay yeah yeah i hear he invests in
hard seltzer and cannabis companies
not he's an alcoholic and a stoner and
we haven't purchased any of the real
estate he's renting everything yeah it's
just like
the ring the receipt i don't know it's
very sketchy
it's very sketchy he rents his watch
do you see the price tags in his shirt
like i don't know i don't know if he's
supposed to tuck him in or if he took
him from sat like i didn't know what i
was looking at
you guys adam's poor he's out of control
i'm obsessed with like
who in comedy is our emcee hammer
oh who's gonna like i think it's uh
brendan trub our theo
like well are those guys building 40
million dollar mansions in oakland on a
mountaintop
like rich probably like no wouldn't you
when you see comedians make money
and you're just like no one taught you
about money don't teach me about money
yeah no either so i made a lot of dumb
mistakes i felt like
i and i'm saying this now i've been
saying this for the last like
six months where i'm like i've only now
feel like i know even the smallest bit
about money like
now i'm like no i kind of get it i blew
it all the way yeah but in 10 years i
bet i'm gonna look back and be like oh
my god
what did i didn't know anything that
boat wasn't two million dollars
why did i buy a boat why did i not look
online and compare the price to the
vendor
shit look online i should have just
looked online
where all the reliable information is
the guy they sent me their boat guy
how was i to know he was wiz khalifa's
boat guy
he seemed reasonable he had a tiger in
the backseas
i was like whatever business is business
respect the hustle i had to meet him in
international waters it's how you do
boat business
so fucking it's just funny because it's
like you
people will try to fuck you that's how
you know you've made it
when people try to fuck you so i had uh
this guy this uh
my the uh my the old house um
okay good i have so much shame about
money i'm like the old ha ha i thought
that could
i still have weird shame about uh money
but um
uh the old house i had like a the pool
was like
going under the patio or something and
uh
this guy came over he told me it was
gonna cost 300 000 he said that we have
to pull the whole patio up
move the house by the way this is a
house that tim allen built and i'm not
joking
um
but you have to play that sound effect
imagine we have it i wish i wish that
was the only there was only one
big button and it was just that noise
that i bring up tim allen so frequently
on this podcast that we have a button
i mean it's the best it's the best is
that home improvement
like yes yes i don't remember that much
of it
i remember just that's my boy just
walking around
my house jerking off to jerking off
to all of the tool time
uh no and just being like
that was like my favorite noise for for
uh 25 years
that's still my favorite noise it's so
weird
to have a favorite noise yeah yeah so
one of the other way so number two is a
balloon deflating number three
three nails on a chalkboard i love it
i'm a weirdo
it's such a but it's funny to have like
um a favorite thing
um but no so tim allen i remember
because one time the first house i ever
bought
i was uh like was the biggest deal to me
i didn't know anything about money i
thought if to buy a half a million
dollar house i thought you had to have a
half a million
cash like i had no idea how it even
worked right
i know my and my business manager is
like well let's let's
i was like well business
he's like let's just pay it off slowly
and see how long you're going to be
there
but i had the money to pay for it all
right and so i'm like but we should just
and he's like no that's not how you do
it and then
for the longest first still to this day
i'm like he's stealing all my money
i don't know anything about money but
i'm like he gives me like one piece of
advice i'm like
that seems like you're stealing all my
money
he's dane cook's brother-in-law that's
it
i was like if dane uses him
he's single he's switched is he
available
i hear he's single and in jail perfect
i wanted to do a uh i think i brought
this up to him and he didn't think it
was uh particularly amusing
a show called finding cook's money and
it's just a reality show
this was like five or six years ago i
was like and he's like
that kind of ruined my life for about
five years so you should do
a show about you trying to find all the
money
because he did buy a bunch of stuff with
your money what if you just went
and then you show about your dad's
cancer
[Applause]
man that seems fun to relive all that
life trauma that i went through you know
what people want to see not your stand
up
you go find your mind you and your
expensive hot air balloon
like i just was like i thought that was
such a good idea i thought it was going
to go over great i
kind of did it um i have so many
questions about um
your wedding uh and all of that kind of
shit
um have you written your vows and who's
officiating
well this is written here no haven't
written the vows yet
i'll do it i'm gonna do uh i'm going to
do
uh like i did with my engagement my
proposal
and just black out and be like i love
you you lost for the longest time hair
like it
raven no you're right you got a sexy no
no because you're gonna get up there and
you're gonna go like look i didn't even
want to get married
oh for sure like i never thought i came
into one moment no for sure i have to
write it down and
and just be like stick to the script
because as a comedian
i know i'm just going to revert to you
notice that like i'm talking to you but
i'm also like
i've been doing this you guys are going
to have so much footage of me like
talking to you but then
you've looked at me twice i know but we
both do that we're like
yeah it's like it's like hey hey we're
having a conversation but really for the
audience at home
just for sound i'm coming out yeah we're
both like just like in our camera and i
know that that
i don't want the wedding to be that
where we're like looking at each other
and then when i get the violence i'm
like
get away uh to the audience well because
that's awesome who's
who i'm really doing this for your side
is all gonna be comedians just like
fucking pranking you and being
idiots making fart noises and shit yeah
there's just like a laser
[Laughter]
i have to attack it like a cat that is
so funny
to do a laser pointer on someone's face
for your wedding to like love some jobs
i mean you have to fight she like wanted
to be really serious because i want to
have a joke wedding
and a joke funeral i i think joke
funeral
for sure 100 i'm coming down for like
from a crane
for sure this is what i want for my
funeral and i've thought about this
i want to have i'm kind of weirdly
obsessed with hot air balloons and i've
only ever been in them once and it was
the most magical day of my life
you've brought up hot air balloons twice
in the last five minutes yeah and that's
why i think i'm on this hot air balloon
kick
uh this is what happened when uh i was
in a hot air balloon for the first time
wanting to get in a hot air balloon my
whole life
go with my ex-girlfriend and we're
taking this hot air balloon ride you
really said it's
fire it's over a paper thing it's a bad
convention but i'm a dangerous boy
please have your next special be called
dangerous boy
i'll pay you i will literally what do i
do dangerous boy
and it's me with a popped leather jacket
with a
collar we just do all of our uh
uh special title and posters as pranks
like what we should just we should have
other comedians have to choose your
title
and poster and then you have to do it
yeah that's i love that
you have to write an hour around the
title
dangerous boy idea like that would just
be such a funny
like we'd never do this because we're
all like workaholic greedy
idiots that don't really get to like do
things for the love of the game anymore
but like if we because i always want to
do a stand-up show and we did it a
couple nights at this show i used to
host when i was like 22. that it was
everyone does someone else's act
that's fun and you're just making fun of
your ears fucking around and
but it just cuts too deep you're like i
do yeah someone gets up and they're like
hey
my
but my pussy material is really good
it's rock solid i guess
i guess the house didn't pay for itself
um
you know yeah then you start getting
defensive yeah you're like it's not it's
actually not like that uh okay well do
you have a boat
like anything that everyone gets more
pissed throughout the throughout the
night
no doubt i'll just go cry on my boat
um but i uh i love the idea of
i like how i popping them like like it's
alcoholic
like like it's a beer like another one
down it's
bottom elder water of the flower
what is it
by the way i think a lot of our friends
are illiterate
have you noticed that
who reads the ads on your podcast
no i i go so what's it about yeah i'll
summarize it uh
does your dick not work by the way
that's all my sponsors are about
about flaccid decks and it's like you
want to get your dickhead
stop listening to me talk just turn this
off
like it's not that the reason your dick
isn't hard is because you're listening
to them and then they turn it they mute
you and go
[Laughter]
oh that's all i needed to do i've been
such a fan for so long
i thought i'd like the sound of her
voice yes i'm brought to you by roman
hey guys if your dick's not hard yeah
because you're listening to three dudes
talk
yeah it's just it's just like how to
clean your butthole
uh it's like by the way it's so funny
because it's like all the ads that could
never go on tv comedians start
podcasting like oh the butthole ad the
love yeah the butthole
yeah and then finally a place we can put
our butthole wipe out i got a t-shirt
that says
it says like talk to me about my
butthole and
i'm like hilarious i'll i'll
like wear it when i like go work out and
chloe was like you're not wearing a
shirt that says talk to me about my
butthole
out in the world i love this because
famous men think if they got sent
something they have to wear it like as a
clothes i
i have so many shirts that i'm like and
chloe's like
should we just give this away and i'm
like well i was giving it i gotta wear
it i have to wear it what choice
what choice do i have they gave it to me
it's 100 cotton so it's quality it's
quality material
and it's i'm going to the gym tomorrow i
only have 700 other shirts so
i only have all those workout shirts
that i bought specifically for working
out but i have to wear this butthole
shirt
because i was given it it really is like
a tricky like um
they give you like uh swag from like
shows you're on or whatever
i feel like i can't wear those because
it's just like oh yeah you work okay
yeah i don't yeah i give all of those to
my mom and
100 of every time that i facetime my
mother
she's wearing a conan o'brien shirt or a
colbert shirt or a conan shirt or an
ellen shirt
100 100 of the time that is so
sweet it it is but i know it's just like
my mom is so prideful
you won't buy her other clothes you mean
no she's so prideful that like
she i know it's almost just like
you can have a conversation not
involving
me and the stuff that i've been on like
i feel like her friends are
getting to the point that they're like
we get it he was on
what he was on the tonight show and
did he give you that t-shirt penny yeah
okay
yeah yeah uh-huh yeah like it's such a
it's such a sweet
it is it's sweet but i'm like i'm
looking out for her friendships because
i think there's a few people that are
hanging on by a thread
they're like see so we don't even know
these
things the craig killerborn like it's
like also half the fucking shit i have
like it's all been canceled
yeah it's like super deep code stuff
networks that have been cancelled
yeah she yeah my quibby one piece that i
gave
penny i'm so we have like a okay so we
have a couple things in our past that
are just like funny and weird
so weird yes explain explain to me i'm
gonna write them now um
uh okay and then well one time
someone hacked my phone that's right got
my phone number no
someone put my phone number on reddit i
think and for whatever reason not that
yeah no exactly emily is just like it's
job security she'll create a problem and
then solve it i'll do it um
but uh no there's sugar in my gas tank i
don't know how that happened i'll fix it
can i say that the fourth beverage in
you get it you're pissing yourself it's
starting to boil in there
you're so stupid have you ever had
anyone come to you about doing a biopic
about a famous comedian
uh yeah your early on i
was almost played belushi in a biopic
and they didn't make the movie and then
they came back and then they were going
to make the movie
again and they went with like i think it
was josh gad was then attached and then
he wasn't attached then emil hurst
jim belushi and do an impression no the
we just went out to dinner and he's just
like
mm-hmm yep you're the guy i think you're
going to be the guy i was drank a lot
yeah i think that was it i was just like
another one i passed out and fell down
the stairs and he's like it's a job
this is this is like comedians are the
best in the world they do not let shit
slide i was like i was like i'm gonna be
able to get away with that stutter when
you fucking no i thought
i thought you were doing it as like a
drunk person no it wasn't actually but
it's just
my mouth it is
the fucking worst one when you send it
like a text it's like a zinger and
there's a fucking
typo and you're like fuck man then you
have to like so what was the
we were talking about the weird things
put my number on reddit yeah and the way
that which happens like a lot and you
get weird pranks and weird stuff
this prank or whatever was happening was
just
many different numbers sending me
photos of you naked on a toilet
pretending to be
you texting me oh yes
i took like a prank photo on valentine's
day
like it was probably seven years ago
naked i wasn't naked but i'm like
sitting on a toilet and i'm like
and i'm like oh yeah and i put it on
like my instagram or something i was
like
yeah i i just blasted on like happy
uh valentine's day everybody or what you
know and i'm sure it was like a
hilarious caption that i had
i bet it was so good so well thought out
and yeah then they sent it to you and
just booked the belushi pic yeah and no
and then you were like hey
uh are you texting me this and i'm like
no i texted with the person for like
three days
yes thinking that it's me and i was like
and i was like it was this thing where i
was like
this is this is how much i like you yeah
i was adam's like doing some weird
flirting like it'll pass like i'll just
pretend
like next time i see him i'll just
pretend he didn't send like
maybe he's just going through something
like i was i really treated i was like
i was like it was so inappropriate and
weird and i was like oh hi you're so
crazy
like i just was like but i remember then
you texted me and you're like oh my god
someone's been texting
that and pretending that it's you and i
go
uh i as a joke i'm like haha it is me
and did you like those dick pics
or something like as a joke not knowing
any of this is really happening
and you were like wait what sends me an
even bigger spiral yeah and you're like
wait what like and then it was like an
hour later so i could just tell you were
like
wait it's so seriously are you aren't
you and i'm like no i'm not
and you're like no honestly now i can't
tell if you actually sent me all this
stuff or
did you or didn't you know chloe's like
how much was the ring
no and then i like felt really bad and
being like hey i want to be absolutely
clear i am not sending you dick pics
or weird messages but someone that just
sent me a bunch
would have to cover his ass
yes sir yeah this is i'm literally
this is making everything you say is
making this worse
absolutely but i remember being like
just ignore it just just like i was like
turn the other way and just be in denial
about it forever because you can't lose
this friendship
yeah and then like a week later you come
and you're like there's a homeless
person at my house asking for your mom
and i was like what yeah i thought you
were like on a bed
i was like he's just lost his mind every
exchange i had with you for like a year
was so
no it was it was a neighbor of mine i'm
on like a huge
text chain because like
the we live in like the hollywood hills
but it's like really close to hollywood
boulevard
so we just
[Music]
i've got to go it's a long drive home
i've got to go break up with her
sorry just realize this is shit i do say
whoa i'm slipping and so uh there's just
like homeless people
are since covet specifically uh there's
a lot more of them and they are coming
and they're like sleeping in our
in garages and yards and it's kind of
scary when you like go to walk down your
stairs
and there's like a guy with literally a
tent set up and so this woman's like hey
uh i don't know if whitney cummings
lives in the neighborhood but there's a
homeless man
here that says he's looking for whitney
cummings mom
and that was her boyfriend yeah and i
remember and then i texted you like
hey does your mom live in my
neighborhood because there's a homeless
man that is like which by the way
uh even if she did she they wouldn't
know that yeah for sure
maybe your mom just has a weird fling
with this yeah hey
we know your mom's probably like a meth
addict and her deal was looking for her
like he was like what no stop trying to
make the connection adam
adam's like hey i'm just trying to hook
this up homeless guy i've been saying to
your mom can you help me find her like
no
he just got a knife he's like where's he
coming he's mom you're like oh i'll find
her
hey don't worry you're looking for her
what a what's the rusty knife i've never
processed that like i don't know what
that that's just like one of the
weird dangerous things that happens to
you as an adult
i feel like it happens all the time i
think when you're like i'm not going to
process that
i know i should has that ever happened
to you like a dangerous thing with a fan
or like
like something where you're just i'm so
chloe's always like well why are you
i'm i like if someone gives me a shot i
take it 100
of the time i'm like i'm so
bad like my man must be so funny i've
i've actually stopped
taking shots because they're next to me
and i'm like
yeah you're like uh meanwhile i'm just
barreling down the line adam shows up
with like drugs he's like here
drink this don't mind the syringe mark
with the tape
they're just like what's this little
hole
i don't know bill cosby told me how to
i've been riding with bill a lot lately
we do a zoom podcast from prison it's
not a bad idea
did you see it it's not a bad idea it's
still killing it did you see he like in
what way
a few years or not a few years ago like
a handful months ago he had to be like
taken to court or something and like
he's walking with the mask on and he
pulls it down
and to the camera it goes like like his
like does like a bill cosby like mm-hmm
face-to-face the jello jiggler face yeah
and i'm like
it still worked watch the insane video
with the mask and i'm like
still laughing i'm like this guy
this guy is divided he's like dude
custody he's still funny yeah dude i
don't know if you saw that he walked in
how funny would it be if like if bill's
like ghost riding someone's career
and they like skyrocket they'll become
like the biggest
comedian in the world and then it's
revealed that
bill cosby from prison is just like
gentle with the pudding
but it's actually so funny because it's
like the idea of a casting director or
someone to be like
phil cosby for this or whatever and
they're like you can't cast him did you
see the video of him walking the car
like from the car to the courthouse it's
like i think we just briefly just think
he's so
talented he just oozes you get him like
charlie chaplin lucille you just don't
get him like that
they don't make them like fully baked he
goes behind the judge he's like
and you're like bill the judge just goes
gee get out of here bill
you are america's dad
[Laughter]
get him out of that jumpsuit put the
sweater on we all want to see it
i do feel like okay this is a very hot
tape and there's obviously a joke take
but the fact that we are like oh my god
humans like you're just canceled culture
so crazy we did
have a black rapist be america's
dad yeah four no for sure like 30 yeah
and we still
like them i feel like we're actually
pretty forgiving species yeah
yeah i feel like we got rid of the
the the the worst offenders you know
um but then you look at some of them
bill cosby
like he's still he still is funny even
though he is a sexual deviant yeah
and belongs in prison maybe he releases
a special from prison
about how donates the proceeds
to sure or he doesn't and he just like
has a hilarious amount of jello in his
prison cell that he gets from the
commissary
he's doing bits he has a podcast jello
sponsors it
i like how cosby i don't remember any
like real cosby bits
he wasn't like my favorite comedian
growing up it's just those goddamn jello
commercials
by the way i don't have to tell you
doing a commercial
to be funny in a commercial is so hard
because you have no co you have no
control over it you have no control over
what takes they use
it has to be global so really funny
people get these big super bowl
commercial stuff and then you're like oh
it's like embarrassing
he was funny all the time in commercials
the guy the guy's who else's career has
been helped by commercials
uh mine
no i did i did a uh it was like
i i did this movie it's a disney
it was like a disney movie that uh
it was put on disney plus and it was
like a camp movie that i'm like of the
fun camp counselor
and it's called magic camp and there's
all these little kids
in the movie and one one of the dads had
not seen
like the dad mom hadn't seen anything
i'd ever been in but i was just in this
commercial
where like they rip my chest hair off
and i go like
whatever i make some insane voice and
they were like
wow that's pretty incredible rise
and i'm like what's that and he's like
just from the geico commercial or
allstate or whatever it is the old spice
guy
and they're like from that to this
that's pretty and i'm like and also the
commercials airing like
as we're shooting so it's like jeff
disney or who's ever running i should
know who's running the disney
corporation
disney jeff disney's like we gotta get
this kid jeff
disney who is it who's running um
i think it's uh mickey
mouse oh my god mr mickey uh well that
doesn't seem plausible it's just
it's walt's grandson
so fucking dumb i did read somewhere
that um
uh uh one out of every three people at
disneyland are playing closed cops
i'm obsessed with disneyland i did i've
also heard that too and that's why
there's never
like you see at like six flags have you
ever there would be like a
huge fight that breaks out and then at
disneyland it never happens because
every every dad that's just like holding
cotton canyon there's no kids around
it's a navy seal yeah he's like killed
osama bin laden
like they literally they say that like
when because i went there
with two people that are on like a like
a disney franchise show so they're like
gods and you got like a tour you know
yeah and
um i wasn't you know i'm just like being
an asshole you know what i mean the
whole time the
dick head on the tour and it's like man
i don't want disney and anti-semitic
i'm seeing the dick sure you're like you
say all the shit and then you say
mickey's not even a real mouse and
you're tackled no
there's a red dice it's like me and my
wedding
just like walking just a hole appears
and i've fallen um
no but i uh uh uh was oh yeah walking i
was being the asshole i was like hey
this isn't already but the pedophile
like i just whatever being like the
dickhead
and he goes oh no no they go um
downstairs
down a like a shoot or something so i
was like huh
and he was like oh yeah if you just are
at disneyland and just
sit long enough and look around most
people are parents and they're like
looking for their kids
but if you look around if there's like a
single man
alone standing for long enough another
man will just come up to us and be like
hey buddy you're coming to me man
and you he was like if you just look
long enough it's like hey bud
upstairs what are you okay but you would
never know what's happening well
maybe i'm one of those guys that just
loves disneyland
yeah you are going to go to i will get
to see this cool
extra room what's with the adults in the
dip
like i've seen all of disneyland i love
disneyland
so you're saying i got it i just gotta
look there and it's like
just like put a half a carrot in my
pants just
and they're like hey buddy and then i
get to see because the kids
i know but what just if you're going to
play a man that's attractive children
why won't you just do what you do with
women
and do that why do they have to because
you got to be extra creepy
you got to be extra creepy you got to be
like i don't know i just
i don't think you're making child
molesters seem really disney like
fun and mischievous no it's disney so
you got to play
this is you have to be like this is a
basically a children's movie about a
pedophile
so you so you have to do it as um a
cartoon character
you gotta be like
[Laughter]
you put a wig on what was the um what
was this
fantasia you have to do it as as mickey
and fantasia remember fantasia
i did i hated it because i'm just like
god another
of these songs i got an argument with
someone yesterday
about uh not liking fantasia
i was stunned you've been bringing it up
a lot it's my opener
you love small talk i'm awkward it's
small
i don't know you're like on a plane
you're like uh yeah um one vodka soda
fantasia and the person she's like uh
hi yes or no fan or no
so you love it you no but i like the
idea of going on the so you like when
the brooms are like
sweet 11 minutes of that
uh i just remember like how much are
they sweeping this goddamn room
cleaning that's not done by women is a
wonderful thing to watch
yes hey fair enough i don't why do i
make those like bitter woman jokes i
haven't cleaned in 10 years
i'm like yeah you know the woman
cleaning
is kind of a day off as if there's just
like a uh
a kevin james style character in your
life who's just downstairs he's like i
wish you'd clean around here
every now and then right no one like
that turn into the original roseanne
well steer clear from a lot of that yeah
yeah twitter um by the way
i bet she's still super funny though
much like cosby
dude dude i'm just saying if you
motherfuckers would just
decide to prioritize entertainment
a show with roseanne and bill cosby
where the proceeds
go to the causes they hurt i don't
what's why not put these mother put the
people that have caused all this damage
to work
to work why not hey i'm tuning in
at least to the first episode just to be
like is this gonna be good
yeah no just sort of like i got a
fucking seat you know
and then it raises so much that's some
must-see tv because people
hey nbc no not nbc's not the place
triggered uh no no um
no but uh it's just fascinating to me
because yeah when i was
working with roseanne everything she
said and i couldn't tell if it was
like conditioning like because you just
know bill cosby's funny or if it was
like if this was a new person i didn't
know if it would still be as funny
but we couldn't even audition actors
with her in the room because she would
if she would read with them we would be
laughing so hard that the
poor actor acting with them couldn't
like do anything you know yeah
she was like my favorite specifically
and i work with
goodman now on the righteous gemstones
and i just like
love him he's though john goodman
is john goodman laurie metcalf i mean
there's like
three people that really like fluster me
to a point of like
i just i can't really talk to them well
yeah
yes and and i'm like i like him so much
that and he doesn't give you a lot like
he'll just like stare at you he doesn't
like you yeah he doesn't
yes for sure told me uh but he when he
laughs at something that i say or like
like he
like if he were to like laugh like at
the end of a take
i'm like i go home like i like go home
like i'm like i'm wearing a cape
just fucking chloe being like you're
john good
one tank
dan connor is my dream man like he is oh
dan connor
my dream he's such a fucking stun he's
such a stud
but i there was a time that i was
working with him that i he would
when he would talk to me like do you get
starstruck bending i mean you've worked
with such big celebrities
uh not usually by actors
just because i'm like i also do that
yeah and you and
my thing is whenever i get panicky with
especially a man if i get star trek i'm
like you're wearing makeup
you're wearing makeup that's how that's
how my dad and my uncles take me down a
peg or two
they're like well you wear makeup at
work and i'm like yeah
i know that's such a by the way
why do they even know that i mean i feel
like no they've
they've seen my dad has like come to set
and they would come to set every year
and my dad would like see them and he
goes
jesus christ how much makeup do you need
and i'm like it's the regular amount
it's your dad bobby lee
no he sounds i do a great impression of
my parents i don't do great impressions
out of many people
like my dad literally talks like this
he'll start and he'll start up high and
he'll get going and he'll say something
and then he'll end it like that
he's like hilarious like his cadence
is so goddamn funny that's how you get
it
that i uh steal from him but he
he loves hollywood and loves he just
loves giving me shit like when i got
when i did pitch perfect i i call them
all excited and was like
hey dad i just booked a like a big
studio movie
um the script's really funny i think i
i'm
i'm gonna do it and i think it's gonna
be a big deal and he goes oh
awesome what is it and is it like an
action movie a baby trailer
and i go uh it's uh i play a collegiate
and by the way i'm like 26 years old
allegiant collegiate
collegiate collegiate collegiate i've
been saying it wrong
my entire life i'm obsessed by the way
i'm obsessed i did this yesterday i said
to someone
um about the mass i was like oh it's
been a while since we've introduced a
new accessory
into yeah it's not accessory
but you can still say accessory sure
that's saying it wrong
much like i said collegiate my entire
life we got a 20 minute fight about this
last night
well you lost i don't know i don't know
if it was ended
here but i can't lose this one no okay
so i call my dad and i'm like i'm
playing a
college aged um but i i'm
because you know why why when do we draw
the line at you have food in your teeth
when someone's mispronouncing someone or
no tell them because i
i came out here my dad says everything
wrong i used to mind that's the best
thing
since life spread yes
uh i i would say uh
let's play it by a year that's what i
said
i would say hey let's play it by year
and then it would it took i think it was
like chloe within the last
year she was like what you could play it
by a year
i left i'm like and she goes what does
that mean to you
and i'm like yeah yeah you're well
figured out in the moment we're playing
it by you
everyone in your life was like what an
asshole he's like i'll text you in a
year yeah
i will play a year all right every year
i'll reassess if i want to hang out with
you
that's so funny and so i told my dad i'm
gonna play this college kid
who uh is in an a cappella singing group
and he's kind of the stud of the
acapella singing group and he takes it
really seriously and it's really funny
and my dad goes it's a singing movie
and i go uh yeah it's a comedy and
they're they're college kids and they're
singing
and it's you know and he goes but you
can't sing we're as shit
and i go i don't know i'm an okay singer
and he goes
bullshit you fucking suck
and i'm like all right well
come to the premiere this is what it
takes buy a suit
now you want to have a very successful
uh comedian child you have to talk to
them like this yeah for sure
that's why i you know and a lot of
people have had this take
i'm like the anti-bullying movement i'm
like
to a point yeah sure you don't wanna
yeah but some
we need some we need a little a little
bullying
character building adversity yeah
because i always feel like if everyone's
too nice then then
then comedy's done especially us like we
need to be able to be rough it's so like
um you know i don't know yeah and i i
also look back i'm finally at the point
of my life where i'm i just look at all
of
the adversity and the that shit of my
mom like never think i'm good enough
stuff like that i'm like oh it helped me
help me help me i just
i need to look at that as good parenting
for the job i chose
for sure instead of going my parents
failed and now i'm just a comedian that
gets to live my dream like
this had this ended well yeah it ended
well it landed fine like
yeah and it's like there's levels to it
like if like also my dad
would say those things to me which
always
i knew there was love underneath it if
he did that and then like
burnt me with cigarettes at night then
then i would say that it was a bad
childhood but
no burning with of me with cigarettes
you know it was just like
it'd be like i'm in a cinnamon movie and
he's like you can't sing we're shit
but that's that's always something when
someone brings something uh adam and
blue i'm obsessed with that like
um where were you last night i wasn't
cheating like what
yeah i wasn't i didn't think you were i
didn't drive to encino and go to
uh this woman uh with the instagram
handle samantha313
score 2013. booking littlebunny
gmail.com yeah because i was like
uh uh uh you're like i mean my life my
childhood was abusive i mean i wasn't
like burma cigarettes
on my left knee or anything um he's like
so specific
well i i i have really bad scars on my
legs because i was uh
you know i'm sure you don't think i know
the story but i don't really i was hit
by a cement truck as a kid
and i i've been doing a lot of podcasts
to talk about my podcast and i feel like
i've just told this story so many
goddamn times
but i was hit by cement truck and i
couldn't walk for like two years when i
was a little kid so i have horrible
scars on my legs
so you're you um i know you feel like
you've told the story a lot and i know
what it's like to be in a podcast like i
told this and i'm bored and whatever and
i know i have to get you out of here
but i mean the way you just blow by i
was hit by a cement drunk
it's just really like i know what it's
like to have a thing when you're like i
don't really want to talk about it
well i'll tell you uh you know what a
cement trick is
can we just start with is it cement or
cement cement
okay i'm just joking i was hit by one so
it could be c-man before we get to your
trauma we can where do we
land on the intonation of cement
is it is it seaming no this sounds like
an interesting story
cement or cement
that's like the story of my life i get
caught up on dumb shit that doesn't
matter it's a story in my life
it's why i will never be married because
i'm just like no you screwed the cap on
weird and i just
you can't be you'll never be a father
you're obviously a bad father and you're
going to leave the baby on that
that i go yeah oh you didn't finish this
okay so you're going to leave the baby
on the roof when we fly okay well fine
this is never going to work
well i finished it all the elderflower
press if that's how you say it per se
prissy there's no way to know how to say
that word
um that one's that one's rough
it's it's not that good there's a reason
there were so many of those yeah i don't
know if they're a sponsor but
you not i'm gonna say not for me
okay not my favorite not for me
but roman calm but roman very much for
me
it's so it's so soft and i'm so bald
oh yeah no normally people drink that
after they put the uh roman numbing gel
on their mouths
there's roman numbing gel yeah for your
dick oh do you not read your i mean you
know
i black out when i read it we can't tell
them about this gel
we should know we shouldn't know we
shouldn't let them know you know i can't
read so they just give me the general
they're like it's like dick pills and
hair stuff and i'm like because your
dick doesn't work because your bald ass
head
[Laughter]
you're insecure about your bald ass so
brutal any time someone wants to
say that like men never have anything
hard ever listen to the ads on our shows
it's like your dick doesn't work your
balls are gross clean your dick
shave your dick it's just like jesus men
have fucking insecurities too
the people are really worried about
their balls i'm like i guess my balls
don't smell that bad like i watch
because
because there's so many like we're
constantly getting inundated with like
ads that are like
it's ball powders it's is it musky down
there and they're like no
not really no i don't think so i mean my
girlfriend comes up like with tears
yeah chloe is like yeah it is yeah it is
how much was that ring how much was the
ring
no but for real though for real
that price would ring uh she'll put up
with your ball sweat for another year or
so
um and then uh what do you guys fight
about or do you
no we don't when you get engaged did the
fighting go down or uh
dissipate i do we don't we don't fight
it's so cool
yeah we really don't uh but mostly
like i will get frustrated
like if i'm hungry that's the only time
that we really
if like i'm if i haven't eat because she
will just she can have like one big meal
and then not eat again for 24 hours and
every like three hours i need
a more food yeah yeah and so i'm i will
then then i'll be like
can i get a little help here or
something or like i'm carrying all this
stuff
my hair everything out of nowhere you're
so pissed about something
and if you didn't part your hair down
the middle we wouldn't be in this
situation you're like what
what what is that you need a snack would
you like some nuts
you're right it really is like most of
the things i'm pissed off about
i'm just trying to get it back let's
just play it by a year and she's like
it's here wedding's off
eat more cake have you gotten your tux
no uh it's not we're not
not until the fall so i have like a lot
of a lot of time out of the woods i mean
we will be right yeah yeah
yeah have you have you had to push it
because of kovan i
uh sorry it's not funny i just it's such
a nightmare no it's
such a nightmare like have you wasted
money on venues yes we
had a venue that uh
they just stopped they like went
bankrupt
like a huge venue that goes we're going
to cancel
all events for 2021 and we're like
but our wedding though and they're like
yeah we're just not doing it
if you want to get first if you want to
get married in 2022 we might be back
and i'm like the circuit city
i hate you because i was like he's i was
like is he good i was like
comedians can see when other comedians
are talking
but also they're also thinking of yeah
you're like is it
what would be david i watched him be
like i'm not gonna let you win this one
like when you see another comedian going
no i'm gonna finish this and i'm gonna
you i i'm thinking of the reference
that's gonna kill ya
that is a thing that i feel like
only comedians can do just because
not i mean people can think of other
things while they're talking but
uh comedians are so conditioned to
be thinking about totally different
things while being funny
because on stage when you like really
have your hour dialed in
and you do it every night sometimes
you'll be like what are we doing right
after this
are we going to go to dinner like what's
going on over here there's some talking
over here don't let me distract you
or you're thinking like hey should i do
this bit four minutes from now or
should i replace it with this i'm gonna
pivot to this i'm gonna this guy's
getting kicked out so i'm gonna move
over here and distract people like if
you're constantly in between jokes like
having to kind of
you're managing a tremendous number of
people yeah we are the best aren't we
it's honestly
crowd control with your charisma
um it is so weird what we do the fact
that we walk in and like 2 000 people
that like
like the fact that anyone cooperates i
haven't done it in so long and it's so
weird now
and i do not want to do any of the car
shows outside no i haven't done any i
haven't done stand up in like two years
now
because i didn't uh i did my special and
i was like kind of burnt
i toured a lot right before i did my
special and i was just sort of burnt out
and i was like you know i'm going to
take some time off and i was like
working
acting stuff quite a bit so i was like
yeah and then in 2020 i'll get back on
it and and build my hour and then tour
in 2021
and then uh you know that didn't happen
um
uh i might vomit but
the coffee wait no wait zero perrier
elderflower combo
i need you to youtube loves shit like
this
yeah it's like puke videos
i wish this were like i wish you were
like stevo no i'm good
i got some time no but it's just i i
don't want you to
i'll be fine
i wish you got to put like really loud
really loud uh
like sound like stomach noises during
that silence or it just means
and just like dinner
baby dinosaur hatching
like what was that it's the home
improvement noise in my stomach
did you swallow our home improvement
button
[Laughter]
who have you been starstruck about oh
because this is what i did to john
goodman
i when i talk to him i just start lying
like uncontrollably because i go i bet
he he loves you no
he does but i i i talked about this i
think once on on a talk show and i was
like if he sees it i don't even
miss it um but of course you didn't
because he's just too cool to
watch anything um but he goes on he
would always want to talk to me when i
was summer's day
he loves comics like he just like loves
comics he loves funny people
it's like fun yeah and like howard stern
like these guys that kind of just love
comics because they're like
they think what we do is hard and like
we're not of them and they're weirdly in
all of us when you're just sort of like
how could you
totally there's nothing above you and
the fact that they're like hey so what's
it like doing stand up and you're like
what
like so he would come to me ask me he'd
always be like are you torn did you tour
this weekend
and i was on on a book tour with me and
he was like so where are you going this
weekend
and i like didn't know i mean i knew if
i really thought about it but i i
i also like start arching my back around
him like i have a crush on him
yeah but i also want to be my dad and
i'm also like i don't yeah and you're
like
uh vegas caesar's palace and you're like
really and you're like
no it was waukegan illinois uh
that's what no that's what i did and
because i'm so in love with him that i
start blacking out
and he goes where and i said st louis
which i believe is where he's from he
goes i'm from there what theater and i'm
like
and then i was like i literally panicked
and i just said the paramount
because there's a paramount kind of in
yeah there's a lot of paramounts it's
close it's like good enough
pageant i think is the same yeah that's
what it is but he was like
where is that and i was like is it
downtown is it downtown and then
i'm going like yeah it's downtown it's
new he's like when did they put that in
and i'm like making him feel like old
yeah and they're like when did they put
that in
i want to say 1900 or it could be
2 000. you're just wanting very old and
senile
yeah i'm making my hero feel bad
like he's the best when when he laughs
though because he like
he doesn't he doesn't like give you like
a
he's like he loves it he like really
he's like santa
yeah for me but um he also we did a
pilot together years ago that i think i
got fired from
uh and it was that we played cia agents
in
so it's like him playing a cia it's just
the greatest and he would deliver this
amazing monologue like
like everything he does is brilliant
yeah every choice he makes is brilliant
and surprising and beyond and you
believe all of it
and then he would cut he'd stop himself
and go
i fucked up and we'd be like what no
we're like on the edge of our seat
riveted and he's like i fucked up and
you're like
this is why you're john goodman yeah
because you don't cut corners
yes yourself exactly he it would be like
work
where he finished the scene and he's
like i'm sorry guys
i'm i'm so sorry and we're like that was
incredible
like i feel like if i delivered a
soliloquy like that i'd be like
and i can retire on top and i'm done now
give me
my golden popcorn now mtv
that's my pinnacle which is why it's
like i just feel like there's this
give me my rossie now yeah i was like
at the surfboard of the stack teen
choice awards i told you that was the
best award adam
um uh that's like when i found out that
guys can't be allergic to latex
um
the moment you realize you've been lied
to about a minute
um but i uh uh yeah i just i'm like
just i feel like there's this thing now
with people they're like
confidence is all i need and i just need
to believe in myself you also need to
beat yourself up
and for sure expect a lot from yourself
and
leave work and go i feel like i could
have done better i'm not saying you're
not enough and you're not good and
you're not
like everyone's like whole thing is like
i'm enough totally
but you could be you could be better i
know i mean
goodman ran around fucking stella adler
theater in the 80s and was like
no he was like fucking do it again yeah
and that's why he's john goodman
sorry i think he has the coolest career
too i think he
like to be able to be a huge tv star
then be legit a huge movie star
and amazing on a multi-cam which is very
hard to do yes
yeah he was able to do everything i
think i told you that yes
we've had a couple like we've had a
couple cool conversa like you
i love you for so many reasons but one
thing
that's so awesome stop drinking this
music so i'm gonna get involved now
because whatever you're doing is
self-destructive
like you are you are
that puts a film on the teeth i don't
know
i don't know what it is and this brand
is called extra peach you've drunk
everything except
can so what's going on with your fucking
company dude
we left them somewhere i just drank one
it was good
they're delicious no i actually it
tastes like ginger ale yeah they're
really good that one that one
there's a there's a this is a bunch of
different uh flavors so oh now you're
gonna promote it
i wish i knew the amount of flavors i
just went with a bunch of
i love i'm really good he's an angel
investor they're all like can you
adam you're every time you have an
opportunity who would ever ask questions
about this yeah you just said
uh bill cosby's really funny and then
talked about can within 15 minutes of
each other
hey um you know that whole blackface run
you went on and then you were holding
can
do you mind i know you invested it all
but like do you mind maybe not
doing the blackface thing right next to
her holding up the camera
they're gonna give me your money back
can they give it back
has the company ever returned an angel
like hey we're
good actually you know what thanks but
no thank you
actually if he could not bring it up
ever again uh we'd appreciate it
the gag order um but i love this because
it's i ca i love a double pun
that you don't realize is a double punt
later um i'm obsessed with
you usa shows are always like three puns
in one
it's like suits okay there'll be a show
called like like um
and they're wearing what i know
it'll be like wild card and it'll be
like
a guy that is like a car dealer in vegas
and he's a wild man
and his dad owned a greeting card
business or something
and he's he inherits the greeting card
business
in the will and then has to go yeah and
olivia wilde
it plays a girl like it's always like
something where you're like why did you
need this many puns in the title
call it anything well workaholics is
kind of that
we're calling alcohol working yeah
that's two but that's like
also there should have been more and
it's funny because yeah that's been my
problem with your show
yeah there wasn't enough the double
entendre could have been a triple
yeah there could have been extra tandras
so yeah
no but enjoy but workaholics is extra
peach no because we're going
to stop promoting other companies
besides yours
jesus um but uh
uh like like what was the other one
there was one that was like lucky strike
or something
yeah it's about a kid named lucky
he's a these are baseball oh
i like boulder better yeah we have a
good writing team
we don't go bad idea we're like oh
is there no more lucky uh and he's also
you know fucking strike on sunset the
bullying yeah and then
uh he wins the lottery and does his life
turn upside down
you know it does does he strike out
because he has too much money
but he keeps making bad decisions
and uh is the stripper that accuses him
of rape named lucky
you know who she is you know she is
lucky if you don't catch chlamydia
there's not alcohol in here i'm not even
drinking the weed drinks
oh fuck um do you watch television tv
i can't watch tv without feeling like
work without feeling like
jealous or like or like i don't watch
um work sometimes like comedies really
me either
i mostly watch uh except yours
like prestige tv i like i like really
boring shit that other people like you
watch that i like watch
like not to shit on downton abbey but it
doesn't seem like a show that i would
watch
but i watched it and like really enjoyed
it it's probably soothing to you because
you don't have to go like i would have
said it this way or
i know that guy yeah he didn't deserve
that like there's always just a little
bit of like background noise when i'm
watching something where i'm like oh
fuck
yeah if it's like even remotely similar
to the type of comedy that i would do
i i don't even it has to be like so
far removed i love the idea that you
like meet
someone at like paul rudd at a party and
you're like hey nice to meet you he's
like what it's like i don't watch
god like it's funny because comedians
have no we don't i feel like i'm the
only community that watches other comedy
specials
you're really good at that like when you
you like
came over to my house and you were you
mentioned like specific things
so from like 30 or 40 minutes into the
act
like sometimes like friends will mention
the opening bit and you're like oh i do
that too i like
because i like to see how they people
start their specials yes
and then i'll usually turn it off 10 or
15 minutes in and be like
i've seen him i got it i've seen him do
it fuck the stool within 15 minutes i
got it there's nowhere to go from here
well they're
yeah well there's a lot to cover on that
stool
we got it um one of my first bits
that was so stupid speaking of stool
fucking i used to do like
really dumb bad bits where i would do a
bit
called hot mic can i tell you something
about let me just i'm interrupting
because
i'm only gonna know when people insult
themselves and i disagree with their
insult
well you haven't heard the bitch i want
to defend you against yourself i
think you need to listen to how dumb out
loud
as your dad and god
jesus i know how to make this funnier
you did you did a bit called hot mike
where you i would go
it the hot mic sounds like a dumb bit
when your dad is doing it
and i would go and i go this bitch
called hot mike and i come up and i go
hey how's everybody doing tonight and
then i take that out of the and i go oh
and then i committed so hard for like
two and a half minutes be like
the skin is boiling and i'm like taking
people's drinks and pouring it on my
hand
and it was so bad and so dumb but i
loved doing it like i would love i loved
doing that at the improv because people
were like
what the fuck is going on i don't think
here's what i will say
that is some is so hard to do what
you're
because i think i'm just like giving you
credit for i mean i haven't seen it
i would like to queue it up right now
yeah um but no
i i'm just thinking what you're doing is
sorry because i get so self-conscious
and insecure
and a lot of times comedians that uh
whatever uh peacock or posture is being
like really confident
like i couldn't do that
like i'd have to the audience would have
to be so fucking with me
you know what i mean sure that i i don't
know i would i feel
like i don't know if i would do it now
it was before like i
figured out like who i was where like
i feel like the my comedy's changed now
that i'm like telling stories about my
life
and it's more about me and i'm not just
doing like one
like standalone bits like that in our
20s how would we have had any like you
know what i mean like we're like
that was the fun like when i look back
and i'm like god that fucking special
like oh that was fucking joke it's like
at the time yeah that was pretty like it
was funny it was like what
whatever you can't judge it with you
know
what you would do now like i i remember
seeing you and just being like fuck like
you're one of the only comics that i
that i watch and i never was like
i feel like that's just me like
funny but like cheap like funny but like
you're better than that
i'm saying like i just you were always
just like fucking would just destroy and
you're always about the audience because
so many comedians
myself included um i'm saying this
because i regret it
the first like like eight or ten years i
was just trying to get like
mark maron in the back to think i was
fine you know i was so thinking about
and i was and i remember seeing you for
the first time being like oh he's trying
to get the
audience he's here for the audience sure
saying and i feel that was because i
worked at the
improv and i knew who knows i'm just all
i knew all the comedians
and knew that like they only see me as
the door guy anyways
that's so interesting but you know that
we're sitting in the back going like
fuck this guy
i mean because it's like when you're
starting out and it's so clear you're
about to be the next
guy there is this like coldness where
i'm like oh he's gonna be the next thing
like you can tell if how funny someone
is based on the number of comedians that
talk to
them in the hallway and if you the time
i knew i started getting
some getting good on stage is when the
community is like okay
or when people don't compliment yourself
when i sucked i'd come up be like good
set
and if you come off and you're good
there's like a weird crowd right and
you're like
okay got it got it i can get killed do i
mean it's
always like comedians or if the
community is just like
that you really respect like that was
fucking funny you're like okay i yeah i
feel like there was
once i started to get good that's when
like jeffrey ross asked me to do bits on
stage with him
like that's funny it was like
specifically when i
i felt i was getting good and then
jeffrey ross is like
hey i'm actually going up do you want to
like improv with me and i was like
well dad i've made it jeffrey ross told
me i could come on stage and do improv
with him and he's like who the fuck
oh wow jeffrey ross
that does he know that is no problem oh
yeah no he doesn't he doesn't he for
sure doesn't yes
no idea no dad he's the roast master
general
the what the what what what cool cool
cool i work on the railroad with other
he did that's so cool and where does he
live uh
he lives in he was in omaha and they're
in the
lake of the ozarks so what's up with is
larry the cable guy still
like like run nebraska yeah
i i went i uh was like the celebrity
guest
for the cornhuskers football game that's
kind of amazing and it was awesome
and it was like uh that's actually like
the biggest fucking deal
it was so cool so i gotta go there and
it's always packed
they like sell it out every game since
like the 60s
and uh so 90 000 people like i go on
and like just 90 000 people it sounded
like they were losing their minds but 90
000 people going like
sounds like so i'm like
and and then afterwards someone comes up
to me and then i turn around
and i'm speaking to the mayor of omaha
and i'm like this is so surreal for me
and then uh
and then someone comes up to me and
they're like um adam larry the cable guy
would like to see you
so they can call him larry the cable guy
like just not they don't call him dan
whitney no they call him late
i think they call him layer of the cable
guys so you know so that you're not like
whoa
uh and they're like oh oh oh and then
and then they're i'm like this is the
most
nebraska thing in the world to get
summoned
to larry the cable guy's private box
and then i sucked his dick yeah if if
only it would help the career
uh and he was just the nicest guy have
you met him he's like
so i don't think i have i was supposed
to do his roast and then i was like
didn't that was like the i remember i
was like given the job of the roast and
then
i was the job was taken away you know
what i mean it was like the first thing
i was about to get and then i like they
were like actually
we have to use this person you know
there was like some political thing
where i was like i couldn't do it
sure i wasn't famous enough or whatever
and they're like i'll put you on the
next one or whatever and i remember i
wrote all these like
brutal jokes about him because i thought
i was gonna be on it and he's like sorry
it was the first time they like
saw your set and we're like and that's
too mean and yeah they were like oh man
no
um and uh and and no and i just like
couldn't do and i was so mad but i do
have a big document of mean rose jokes
about him so whenever i do meet him i'm
like hey i have all these insights i
would love to say this to your face i'm
such a big fan i just like
my whole i've been waiting to say this
to your face for ages maybe you couldn't
get her done
you are so yeah i don't know i will work
on that we'll workshop that one well do
you remember when greg geraldo went on
stage and for
the cause i think i was a writer on that
rose but i just wasn't gonna be on it
and um greg geraldo came out and there
was like you know we read all these
rose jokes that are like so well crafted
and like the whole thing about the roses
like they're
super surgical and tight and boom boom
boom and like not
true and whatever sure you're just
saying the most insane things you could
say to someone
like it's just you're saying just a
herpes
it's like you could just do that you
could just take a scramble game of like
a bunch of words and put them together
and just like make figure out a roast
well that's why i really liked
hannibal's when he was roasting uh
hannibal burris when he was roasting no
justin bieber and it was just it
actually was like so
real that it was uncomfortable where he
was just like yeah man i
um i don't like you
i don't think you're talented i don't
like your music i don't get it
i don't think you're good i don't like
how your voice sounds when you sing
and people are like uh no no no that's a
that's a private like that's gossip when
he's not there
yeah this is a rose he's gonna see that
yeah you gotta say he's first has
chlamydia
and yeah we pretend you're so old and
you can never fuck any you're split like
stereotypes like just like
generalizations yeah and you're all
that's so funny fuck geraldo
would write these fucking brutal perfect
jokes
like this is my like my favorite show of
all time to he said to ice tea
iced tea you're so old you used your
first residual check to buy your freedom
like it's just like whatever you think
about that it's just a it's a beautiful
j like it's a beautifully crafted and
he's like
i'm 48. or however old i see he's he's
not like an
80-year-old man but that's what's so
funny about it he's not yeah
so we can all laugh it's not it's not
true he was he wasn't a slave
like what you know we're like okay we're
just telling a crazy joke
and then for larry the cable guy he just
got up there and went why are you
so popular
he was just genuinely comedian to
comedian just like mad he's like
i don't get it like i write an hour a
year of perfect jokes but
you sell out like i don't i don't know i
can't get it i have to explain to my
family why you're famous and i'm not and
i don't have an experience
what truly is crazy about him is like
it was just a character that he was
doing on the radio
and he was just doing different
characters and that one just hit
i remember living in omaha and my dad
going like this guy's from nebraska
and like i remember him just being
like he had like the the cassettes and
the dvds
and the uh cds of just layer the table
guy jokes
that my dad just like loved and it was
just like wildfire
and and then talking with larry he sort
of broke it down he was like
yeah it was just this character i was
doing or dan and
it just caught on and i just kept doing
it because that's what you would do
i heard is this true or a gossip rumor
um that
he wanted he wanted to do a big show in
nebraska
um and like how much that's scary um
yeah i don't know uh it's a weird size
bottle okay jesus christ
i actually am starting to be worried
about your esophagus this is
too many drinks this is too many
cherry pops there's too many jerks um
promote can i write cannon a marker on
this
can i just start writing i would you
know i'm gonna take the sticker and put
it on all the other beverages
so next time just photoshopped so it's
just floating around
here it's a really bad photoshop screen
we're gonna have you
there's gonna be a can poster behind you
um
i forgot what i was saying but it felt
important oh that um in uh in nebraska
that they
he could only do a show july 4th so they
moved the fireworks to july 5th so he
could do a show the july 4th like they
moved america's birthday so he could do
a show
that seems real like he sold out
memorial stadium he's more famous in
america than america
then it's it they oh then yeah they
moved
i like how long it took me to get that i
was like then america
i get confused too it's seven it's worth
it three hours you haven't eaten and i
know
what happened well coffee shouldn't have
been the second one out the gate
[Laughter]
yesterday someone called me a bitch as a
joke and isla bitch is such a
it's when it when you mean it there's
nothing funnier or when you
just when you're yeah yes
or i mean when you it's a it's just
something that
no one says anymore and when someone
says it when you say it to like a friend
yeah and you're like you bitch it's
funny
dude okay but do not call your fiance a
bitch
that will someone that i'm friends with
will come back when one of my guy
friends calls me a bitch it's
so funny but yeah i can't imagine if my
dude called me a bitch it wouldn't go
but my thing with that though is sort of
like yeah
yes i think the going definition of
bitch i would totally qualify
yeah i don't think i'm a mean person but
i i think base
wait that was i totally missed that
i was like thank you for he agreed with
me wait um
absolutely
[Laughter]
i don't know dude um uh i have more
questions for you i know i have to let
you go
um but uh tell me i want to hear about
uh any celebrities you've been
starstruck by because i've just been
fascinated by that
i i feel like you've worked with like
such big celebrities now
it's so weird like i worked with de niro
and it was
so cool and i i'm a
robert de niro fan but after
what the first time i met him he asked
me to come visit him in new york
to star in a movie with him the movie
that i ended up not getting
because this studio wanted someone else
and zac efron
and uh it was dirty grandpa i think it
was
and uh he called me to new york to meet
him and he wasn't wearing shoes
in the middle of winter and i
immediately was put to ease i was like
i'm meeting robert de niro god i got
this is insane and then i met him and it
was like
bob how are we doing
you're barefooted so we're basically
together yeah i'm like
married it is the most intimate thing a
man can do toenails is more
intimate i see you guys dick before i
see his feet but he is he is
like john in the way that if you are a
funny person
he loves it so like john i'm not funny
around him because i get too nervous i'm
always bombing
yeah but i i it was the same thing that
happened to de niro that
happened with john that it was like the
first time we had a real conversation
and i'm actively going like i'm gonna
make this
motherfucker laugh and then it took like
a few minutes and then all of a sudden
he like
and just like morphed into laughing
robert de niro which like doesn't emit
sound just like makes the super de niro
face and wiggles he's just like
that is an amazing impression i used to
nanny for him
she yeah what i used a nanny for him and
the first time i met him
they offered to fly me up to new york
and i go oh no i've got miles you don't
have to pay for that which is the
dumbest thing i've ever done because
he's a billionaire
he could afford it i met him at his
apartment and no but do you need to
borrow some money
oh you want to fly me no i can i can
handle it
if you need to borrow anyone to handle
it and my parents are like you don't
even have any miles these are arm
and then they're also like it's an hr
thing we have to fly you
stop got to new york got to his
beautiful apartment
uh his kid wanted to play hide and seek
so
five minutes good to know emily signs
ndas and honestly i did not i did not
sign one for him oh good
uh so we used to i met him five minutes
later
i'm hiding under his bed with him from
hiding from his son
well i love that he's a fun dad he was
in pajamas and i was like
how did i i feel like this was going so
much i was like ah we're cutting this
it's like and then i'm in bed with
opportunity i'm like oh
emily cut emily's mic that's an insane
story so you were put to ease right away
much like i wonder if you
always wear shoes but it's like i'm
robert de niro
this kid's gonna be he's gonna be
uncomfortable around me
quickly taking his shoes and socks off
as i'm like coming up the stairs
this is just gossip i don't care um i
was uh
in a scene yesterday i had to drive a
car away by the way
there's such a huge part of me that
wants to just knock over all of this
stuff like as a bed be like
um i hate it when you like do a bit and
destroy something like all right so i
guess i got it yeah so i
i'm gonna the amount of time the minute
where it's like okay well we'll just
okay so i owe you a laptop and uh i'm
kind of overwhelmed okay yeah so if you
could just
like you were on a story i go back to
your store
can you venmo me for the i will um i
forgot
okay podcasts are basically it's a lot
of tangents so i'm like i'll be great at
this but you have to get back on
yeah they're getting back on uh that's
the problem
sorry you're on set driving i never even
told you what i'm talking about
kevin costner your hero said to me no
this was john voight
the really good kevin costner that's who
i was struck by you asked me uh 30
minutes ago
wait that's so weird that's so weird i
just thought maybe that was this
no what we were just talking about this
on the last podcast
we were talking about who people say we
look like
do you look like kevin costner no she
people say she does
like no many people have said i've had
multiple people tell me i look like
kevin costner no
that that's like my celeste i look like
kevin smith and then huh
i did that face out it's not true it's
not true
i don't see a lot of both have weak
chins big foreheads
oh wait now i can see it this is why you
wear a mask so much
oh you just had covered you don't need
to be wearing one well i saw him at uh
at like
another one of those hollywood parties
and i was truly starstruck
he's one of those he's like a richard
gere where you're just like
like well but like he just looked like
he's i feel like uh robert
de niro does he is obviously one of the
most famous actors of all time but he's
done comedies
so there's more accessible when people
have done comedy yeah i feel like
he's been he's been funny in movies
kevin costner has never been funny he's
always just the coolest motherfucker
you've ever seen he's usually like
from like 1840 you know what i mean like
he's like he just
is like also like quieter he's always
yeah in like a
pedicoat yeah for sure to see him like
here in 19 or 2017 when i saw him
every time i see him in a movie he's
like won a purple heart in a war so
every time i see him i'm like oh sir
thank you
yes thank you for your service it is
that's when that's when actors like i
think
they didn't really choose this but we're
so much larger than life
because you knew nothing about them yeah
so if there were a war general you'd see
mel gibson and be like
oh my god uh this guy it's braveheart
like you thought
you are william wallace exactly and
that's not
you can't do that anymore no one does
that anymore or they do they think that
i'm adam demand from workaholics and
they're like
chug this
and i do and you do every time and i
can't
stop and i've had cirrhosis for the last
year but
that doesn't who cares the fans want
what the fans want and i'm gonna deliver
yeah we should um stop bringing adam
shots guys
please uh especially in a pandemic
yeah it hasn't happened he's trying to
get sober
uh china gets over for uh five years now
and uh it's not gonna tour
because the shots come there's a lot of
comics that like are
are like elders who i feel like there
was such a big dream
of like fans sending alcohol culture and
they try to get sober and the fans would
still send them and then
you have to tell the waitresses bring
apple juice and i'll pretend it's just
was like
it's you know well i've done that before
where like
i just i i want them to
i want to have the fan be like i bought
him a
drink but i don't want to drink 35
drinks tonight
so i will be like hey if they send me a
jagermeister
bring me coke and then they do and then
from across the bar i'm like
it's a double you i'm so good at
chugging
um and uh and then they're like why is
he talking for a full hour
that's why everyone's so shocked when we
talk for an hour i didn't drink any of
the drinks you gave me
that's why i'm so focused i can remember
i lied to you
that's why yeah that's so funny um okay
so where is your podcast is it on all
um all platforms
yeah stitcher what is stitcher we
actually own stitcher
oh yeah a lot of people don't know that
and i and go to the website stitcher.
i have no idea what stitcher is uh
there's a podcast network isn't it
hey seems real sometimes there's so many
of them no i'll get a thing that's like
uh it's
please say it's on itunes spotify
stitcher they're on
amazon now so who are these fucking
idiots that can't find them
every time every day just you know where
to look
you have shitty wi-fi you're stealing
wi-fi from your neighbor this is yeah
people that are like where can i listen
to it
and i'm like literally if you can listen
to podcasts
if you can send me this comment you can
find this
you'll be able to find it it's so easy
in the amount of time you
reached out to a celebrity yeah you
that's not going to get that's also
another thing of like
we're like i i think we're pretty
relatively close in age
and i think we're in love oh is that not
what you're going to say
no no you're placating me yeah it's
awkward uh
no i just was like no i think we're
similar in age so i think
we remember a time that
you couldn't just like i would never
just reach out to
adam sandler and be like hey so i can't
find
billy madison on tv right now so where
is it airing on comedy central or is it
just yeah
how do i see he's the star yeah
how do i how do i see uh mr deeds
hey hey hey adam uh your movie's in
theaters this weekend can you pick me up
and drive me and drop me off to watch it
like what
it'd be so awesome if me and you could
just go get a chicken parmesan
sandwich you know my job is done it's
now
everyone else's job to make sure you see
this and it's your job to click on my
job's
done it's so bizarre if anyone had said
to me uh
being comedian it's like the best you
get to get up and you can be funny and
it's the best thing in the world and you
also
every fan you have to teach them how to
work their computer
and by the way phone every time they
come with a photo they all the center
like
and i'm like i know you know how to use
this well the thing is is i feel
because i like doing meet and greets
because i like to i like to
meet the people uh you know that like my
shit so
uh but you're right about the phone
thing i feel like we're never to get to
do that again
because you also i take their phone
100 of the time and i'm like or i
i have my buddy who like knows how to
work phones and it's like
yep and we did i took a look because i
think they get it's like it's it's
always like i have a system down
where i'll just say everyone will put it
in selfie not the wolverine to do this
again
uh yeah put it in selfie and when you
come up just do it in selfie and i'll
find it
yeah because they take everyone's phone
and just do it myself
but now i'm like i don't want to touch a
hundred
dirty fans phones you only get 100
people to your shows
no i cap it off at the the like
oh yeah or else you're there all night
so what are you how do you cat what how
do you you only sell the 100 meters oh
you sell them yeah
yeah well i like i'm so it's been so
long since any of us have toured
by the way i kind of st
you're a mate
just besides yours jesus why do you hate
money so much i love
the sparkling classic gold of good
cocky please put it so the camera's it
yeah there we go
and then
can is the only brand you could say
your agents were like let's find a
company we want to invest in his money
but is there anything he can pronounce
um let's see c-a-n peach
no that's too hard for him
is it prissy okay no
just we got to find him something that
he'll be able to
see in and can this is it
we've got it he thinks the word can
spell with two
that's exactly how you spell it correct
i think they knew that you came in the
branding meeting and it was just can and
you're like
yeah we'll add an n so it spells can
like yeah and they're like exactly like
cannabis that's genius and i'm like
like what and they're like fuck dude we
have to miss all the words so that we'll
participate it's like the new toys r us
it's like it's not our backwards yeah
the investor didn't
know how to read and we just over here
you know how all kids are stupid right
uh let's make them stupider yes yes jeff
let's make it yes yes good
good and what should our mascot be i
don't know like a dumb ass animal like a
giraffe on
on skates or something something stupid
like that
yeah yes because if giraffes were skates
they would break their legs
they would break their legs jeff that's
hilarious goddamn you're a genius
jeff disney and that's where he started
and
uh and that concludes our audition for
the mad men reboot
and that she won her i watched uh mad
men in quarantine i watched a lot of tv
and uh i watched my men and i was like
it would be so fun to just be like
uh the dumb guy who's just a genius in
the marketing pitches
that's really funny yeah who's just like
i don't know uh
and it just will give like the perfect
pitch and don draper's like
hates him and is like
well he did it again it's someone who's
like
dumb enough to be really smart once a
day yeah
who's just like dumb gold i don't know i
feel like
it should be a giraffe with with roller
skates that'd be funny
like everyone's just like fuck it's so
good
he's so dumb that he came up with the
part because he knows what just works
for you know what i mean what should we
do
nike these are athletes we need them to
i don't know they should just do it
do what just do it
oh okay uh
that actually works so we mocked up the
giraffe and it's genius so what should
our
what should our logo be like a swoop
fuck it makes me go zoom
i just want to do something no i feel
like doing something no you should just
do it
and don draper's like sick god damn it
hold in his glass of whiskey
like just 90 documents to be working on
uh he did it again this fucking kid
that's so dumb it is
it's weirdly hard like last thing i'll
say we have to go i know
um but uh she's like yeah i'm
gonna piss solid
it's like it's so funny but it's gonna
come out
thick okay
let's go we'll do the we'll do
everything i have to pee too i'm
starting to do this on my chair
yeah you're also grabbing your crotch
like a little girl
like you're holding it in i you made me
laugh i almost feed myself
on something i literally felt myself
almost pee and i was like i'm fine
like i have a fistula now um all right
well i love you
we end these very awkwardly i love it
stitcher
stitcher i don't even see a podcast just
called what was it
a dangerous boy
uh this is important i like that you
wink the uh
the eye away from the kids
i'm good at hollywood stuff
that's such a thing that happens when
you first start getting jobs and you
have no clue what you're doing
i was so worried about the i the first
real thing i got was on this show called
samantha who
with uh christina applegate and i played
like
her assistant yeah it was awesome and uh
she i was so cognizant about like
not staring right into camera
that i was trying to like it's
still a sitcom like you are playing two
cameras like you are opened up to
camera camera right yeah so i didn't and
then finally the director had to come
over and be like
find the lens because i'm just like so
uh
christina i was uh i brought you these
papers and coffee
find the lens right now as you're doing
this bit please uh
here you go you still haven't learned
anything i mean and they're like
we're over here shooting you're doing
the bit find this lens and that can be
your camera
i brought these for you that is because
because it's like you just kind of don't
know and then you but you're pretending
you do you're like i'm an actress i'm
going to pretend like i know what the
fuck i'm doing around here
i got cut out of a bout schmidt they
shot it in technical
with jack nicholson when i was a kid
they shot in omaha nebraska because
alexander payne shoots most of his
movies in omaha
because he's from there and uh i was
working at the grocery store
the first movie was an alexander payne
movie i mean
extra i'm not in the movie and they
asked me because i'm working at the
grocery store to stock shelves in the
background
but all i've heard from hollywood is
like find the lens like you got to make
sure that they can see you
so i was stocking shelves like this i
was like
i was like
[Laughter]
hey to everyone in the background not
calling me out like you're stuck in the
shelves so you know how you do
you know how you know how you do you
know wait not that shelter
yeah just like fucking god and they were
like
uh so hey so this isn't jack nicholson
he's just a guy getting milk
uh you uh you're just stocking shelves
he's speaking to everyone as if they're
all i'm the only one stocking shelves
i'm like
they noticed my stocking shelves
uh and then and then i did it again and
then they're like okay cut
actually you're going to be uh stocking
chills over here
and i'm like i've been spotted
and then they just made me stock up the
moment when
rosario dawson talks about it a talent
agent spotted our new york stoop
yeah nicholson just goes he's got
something
i don't know i've never seen anyone
stock shelves like that before
but it's so hard because it's like in
the beginning you're trying to make your
mark and you only have two lines no i'm
gonna make these two lines memorable and
you walk in and make some ridiculous
this you'll appreciate this the first
who was on the show recently who said
they saw me in
that tv show half and half it was my
first job i ever did
i don't know who it was it was a sitcom
that was on
was it like a black guy and a white guy
and they called it half and half
no um that was a show called mulatto
yeah um
no this was hap what was it about why
was it called half and half i didn't
think about that and there has to be
four black women remember it was like um
it was rachel true
my scene was with rachel true you were
in the spot right yes
my first audition ever and that's how i
got taft heart lead
nice why are you obsessed with me
you pay me yeah um
uh uh and i went to the audition i was
like i'm gonna really stand out
right it's two lines whatever and i in
the scene shore bathroom and i
didn't know anything about and i wore a
bathrobe with nothing under it to the
audition
i showed up ever there you know when
they're auditioning like 10 rolls
that are two lines so there's tons of
people there yeah it was
a ton of people me in a bathrobe
and ben gleeve and a police officer
the two comedians went and like put on
the
outfits no idea
no idea and also so desperate to make it
that was the worst i don't know if you
ever went on like commercial auditions
but i did a lot at the
especially at the very beginning and uh
and then you just walk in and you look
around and you find
everyone that just looks identical to
you it's like bizarro you yeah
they're just like it's just like the
more handsome version of you and you're
like
yep i'm over there or it's just like
they're just like big fat burly guys and
you're like this is
i'm using this group are we sure no
okay now what did you say to the agents
to get us all cut
did we say obese in the
hallelujah
why would i be called in for icy huh um
it's so fucking you find out i know for
me when i used to always go to uh
uh commercial auditions i'd walk in and
find out how i was perceived and i would
go in and because there's so many people
and then you walk in
and then it's some the actor that got
the job like screen testing with you and
the action is like
oh got an annoying wife nagging you
about the stains like it was just
something where i was just like annoying
girlfriend wife and i was like and
you're like grass stains again
really what and then they're like no we
don't buy there's no one ever to marry
her
um and then yeah i did not book
commercial auditions
i just come off too sarcastic people
think i'm being sarcastic and shitty
even when i'm being sincere i'd be like
love evian it's so good
and they're like yeah but you actually
do like why are you being an asshole i'm
like
no i know i do what's your problem yeah
you're like um
great guy i have to pee i love it
all right we're done making me laugh
don't ride elephants i love you guys
this is uh you definitely win for most
beverages of any guests and you also win
for guests that
accidentally shit my way
and you win
for guests that ruined my plumbing the
hardest
what's uh okay but i win though
workaholics podcast
this is important that's the name of the
podcast
and it isn't listen
[Music]
uh
[Applause]
you